[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
everyone happy Halloween welcome to the
2022 edition of the mix neck showcase I
am your host Justin Woodward co-founder
of the mix the media Indie exchange
Indie team and tarabang entertainment
and an advisor on the black game
developer fund as well as black voice
and gaming we're at the gorgeous Wilmer
Sound Studio in the heart of Berkeley
California and I am with my lovely
co-host Candace hey candy hey Justin hey
everybody out there so happy to be here
as always especially right before
Halloween which is one of my favorite
times of the year we are getting super
festive this season we've got a lot of
great game trailers reveal Shadow drops
and Dev commentary for games coming out
this fall and 2023 and Beyond now before
we get started Justin for the folks
tuning in what exactly is the mix next
so for the folks Tuning In the Mix next
is a celebration of Indie devs and their
games where we focus on sharing great
games and their creativity behind find
the development the event was created by
devs Fort devs and at the end of the day
this is all about the games and the
people who make them the streams have
been super awesome since 2020 we have
exceeded 9 million views we appreciate
all of you for tuning in and want to
show you some love by dropping you all
some keys when you see the QR code that
pops up on the screen don't be shy make
sure to snap a pic and enter to get some
awesome games awesome once again we have
teamed up with the Exquisite Folks at
valve to showcase our stream on their
platform in order to support the devs be
sure to check out the mix next event
page on Steam where you can wish list or
play the games that are featured in this
event yes make sure to do that support
the devs on every platform we want to
give a huge shout out to all of our
sponsors for helping us to make this
thing happen you guys are great here
they are and all their Glory shout out
to our broadcasting partners for
supporting the Showcase and the
developers on the stream as well twitch
IGN Gamespot steam everyone else who
co-strings you guys are awesome also
salute to the developers who are
participating they have all contributed
their games and resources to make this
thing possible now
followed by the latest black voices in
gaming the publisher spotlights will
feature the creative Pro Indie pubs raw
Fury tiny build acapura and assemble
entertainment where they will show you
their next hotness that is going to be
fire candy the games for this event are
broken down in the spirit swamp
tetris-like blocks this first block is
dedicated to new reveals and updates
from titles overflowing with creativity
and style we have a date announcement
inside on Music Creation and we will
take a stroll through Brazil with the
exclusive new trailer from sue the real
Candy I can't wait I can't either let's
get started
foreign
I traveled alone as I always did
since if I were to be betrayed my
journey would have become a race against
those with more money and power
and then
I took my first step
onto a Korean ground
it shouldn't be that hard to find a way
out of here
[Music]
and so the mysterious guide finally
reveals himself
it is I boji Apprentice to the greatest
Sage of akriya
why should I believe you a talking wolf
Monster
you my fellow Adventurer are now bone to
this Valley by the stone in your chest
there is someone who can remove that
connection though the way to him is long
and hard
we'll leave this place
together
[Music]
[Music]
it was a hard journey wasn't it
[Music]
hi I'm Rose 9 the operating system of
this phone I need your help or I will be
deleted forever
but don't worry we'll crash the update
together by creating errors come on it's
time to sabotage that system
let's start with bran which is short for
a random access memory a whole lot of
Errors can be triggered in Ram I'm
telling you
I always get lost in Wi-Fi it's just too
much bureaucracy everything needs the
approval of a counter approval assigned
form it's just photos and social media F
I hit a nanosecond how did they even get
in here
[Music]
are you in the mood for some party in
the speakers the xor NR hosts the best
ones believe you me
I've always loved to visit this place Mr
gallery fun with the colors
um you see you see that glowy green
thing that's acid and I assure you you
don't want to touch it use your skill to
make a path for us
unzippa seems to have made itself at
home around here maybe because of the
heat nothing like a toxic exotic
vacation right
you're doing fine but there still is a
long way to go
just to make sure uh if it was up to you
you wouldn't replace me would you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
games the creators of paper trail a
top-down puzzle Adventure game set in a
completely foldable paper world you play
as page a budding academic who's leaving
home for the first time to pursue her
studies on her journey she learns how to
fold the world merging two sides
together to solve puzzles explore new
areas and uncover long lost secrets so
paper trail is available now to wishlist
on Steam with release planned for early
2023
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there is no way back I'm going One Way
Forward
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
so I guess this is a story nobody will
tell how I ended up inside the Twisted
living hell
to be fair I can't recall what I was
even there blurry thoughts and pain
won't stop until I figure how would
happen yes
rather walk
the walk walk with flash before is now
some roughly drunk ass
All Is Lost in memories but even those
are just more paper
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
yo yo yo
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
wow Mr Cool looks divinely elegant I've
never seen anything like it as far as
mixing fully hand-drawn animation in an
adventure experience so fluid so
splendid thanks to sue the real for
showing such an ill perspective of
hip-hop and development culture from
Brazil yes yes
in with the game action from Parish it
was so cool really all the trailers look
awesome up next we are going to get into
a narrative Vibe with story driven
experiences that tug on your emotions
and involve various genres and game
mechanics can't wait to get tugged on my
heart let's go
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're gonna jump to chapter three you
slip under the plastic panel and have to
pause as overpowering hunger gnaws at
your belly in your head something smells
delicious for a moment it's the only
thing you can think about gory your
friend old pirate it's good to see you
ah you're smelling Cory and he's
dripping with Flavor now normally I
would be able to sort of get a hold of
myself but I do not have enough brains
points left in my head to do that so I'm
gonna have to tell him okay well I admit
my hunger's controlling me now now calm
calm friend I have some slime but what
you need is a ruthless interrogation of
your inner self oh man I just want to
ask him for the Slime but again not
enough brain power so I'm gonna tell him
uh that I'm gonna serve him as his
servant forever if he gives me the food
that would be nice maybe someday he
reaches a slim arm through the crack
holding a goblet of slime
when hunger overtakes my failing
self-control so uh you found that you've
grabbed his Savory smelling arm without
trying okay there's my monstrous
Instinct and they're like I like I'm
really fighting against my brains here
which I just like I have nothing I'm
starving and I am just gonna have to eat
my friend's arm you grab gory's arm and
tug with Delirious strength the fear
washing through him smells even more
appetizing
the terrified monster link proves quite
elastic oh chop well I gained some flesh
and guts back and I think I just ate him
you pull and gorey's Paul complete uh
comes completely off chop so good
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey everyone this is James from gold
fire Studios and I'm the director on
Arctic Awakening we are so excited to be
a part of the mix showcase this year and
to be giving an exclusive look at some
new gameplay
[Music]
hey it's me still kicking
come back if you read me
you finished with your beauty sleep
you know I don't need any help in that
department
an Arctic Awakening you play as Kai a
next Navy pilot who crashes in the
remote Alaskan Wilderness and must
journey to find his missing co-pilot
maybe one of those however the icy
conditions will be the least of your
worries as you'll encounter various
Mysteries hidden amongst the trees
at this you'll also be facing the
elements with only a court mandated
therapy robot Alfie to keep you company
's relationship doesn't exactly start
out on the right foot
you know considering the whole Court
mandated aspect and all
but through dialogue choices and the
actions you take that can all change
throughout the course of the adventure
you'll go on together
[Music]
you shouldn't confuse Alfie for just
another robot along for the ride
Alfie is a full-fledged companion
character who will Aid in your journey
in countless ways from accessing
unreachable areas to helping solve
various Mysteries that you'll encounter
you're both lost out here and will have
to work together to find your way
both physically and mentally
my goodness it appears we have found the
source of the light
see they're practically adults no need
to worry like your hotmails and we're
out of here in no time anyway huh
all of this takes place in a massive
handcrafted world for you to explore and
experience chihistorian
we hope you'll join us to help Kai find
his co-pilot and Away Home when Arctic
Awakening releases on Steam and consoles
in 2023
until then be sure to wishlist on Steam
say hello on our Discord and check out
the demo available now for a limited
time
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone great to meet you I'm pip
from normal robots and I'm here to chat
to you about one of our upcoming games
disparity
disparity sees you moving to the
countryside to write your book but
things take a strange turn when you
drink some of the local tea and start to
see spirits
once you can see them it's your new job
to find and remind the local spirits of
who they are before heading up into the
mountain to run a bath house just for
them
if you've already played our demo you
might have met some of our spirit
friends already if not I really highly
recommend it
thank you
as you become both more spiritual by
donating to the local shrines and
friendlier with the townsfolk by
chatting for them on the regular they
start to reveal that not all is as it
seems in your new home
[Music]
the townspeople's problems will lead you
to find new spirits and solving their
problems helps these Spirits feel more
at ease again slowly restoring the
mountain and the bathhouse to their
former glory
that's not the only thing you can do to
fill up on inspiration for your book the
townspeople all have favorite hobbies
that you can join them in from cooking
up great food to singing karaoke
or maybe that should be whaling karaoke
as well as activities like fishing
digging for Treasure and Bug catching
[Music]
in fact we've been so many activities in
the game we've just made a leaflet for
you to be able to track them all on so
here's a quick sneak peek at that
[Music]
however you decide to spend your time on
the mountain we hope you have an
incredible incredible time
look after one Yan Forest Whitney
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
have you ever felt stuck riding your
theater play well those days are over
when you play Once Upon A Jester a game
about improvising your own theater show
we're born to afford and this game is
coming to the Nintendo switch uh check
out our new trailer here
Once Upon A Jester always
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's coming out this year
[Music]
130 years
this ship is our cradle our home and our
grave
nobody alive today will see the end of
our mission
you can imagine how that makes some
people feel
we all still try to do our part
my job is to keep the peace
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
but a lot can go wrong in 130 years
[Music]
I love Monster and I had no idea that
monster loves me back narcel is
fascinating with that one been following
Arctic Awakening and it looks like it is
coming together nicely in this next
segment we've got some cerebral games
that will keep your strategic mind
muscle flexing and then we'll preview
some resource managing World building
simulations with gameplay that range
from cozy to hardcore I love to flex my
strategic muscle
let's work it out
welcome to bubblegum Galaxy a new game
from Sparta Club
bubblegum Galaxy is a cute building
strategy game about rebuilding the
Galaxy by designing planets Style by
tile you play as hakko a young Planet
agritech starting her internship at the
bubblegum branch of The Intergalactic
row of Planet design alas it won't be
easy the office is in this array after
the interior dimensional Universal crash
deleting the majority of the Galaxy
everyone was working on
[Music]
using her trusty computer and the planet
designer's recession software Haku will
have to sign new planets to rebuild what
was lost
planets are built by placing hexagon
tiles on a grid the quality of your
design is elevated using a score value
and to get more points you must play
styles with matching edges and colors
together
[Music]
the software will also suggest missions
such as connecting green tiles or create
a forest of 23 which will award you with
additional points and tiles when
completed foreign
building sessions haco will be free to
take breaks to explore the office and
get to know all characters who will
react to her different actions in game
bass is the guy who's always friendly
and happy to see you although he never
seems to be working
[Music]
Magda is a hip young architect who will
be hack of supervisor but she is in the
field at the prospect laffy is a nice
grandmother-like lady who always gives
you advice when you need it but
sometimes doesn't know how to redo
pente is an organized and competitive
robot who will always be comparing
Hackle scores with their own
as you progress as a planned acrylic
you'll unlock new planets with new
Mechanics for example you will encounter
tiles with elevation challenging you to
manage different heights and figuring
out the best way to connect them
or also animals such as carnivores and
her viewers or you must find the optimal
distribution for them to produce a
healthy ecosystem
asaco finds a place in the office and
rises in the ranks she'll get closer to
her co-workers and slowly find out the
truth behind the deletion of the Galaxy
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everybody my name is tomasala and
today I'd like to introduce you to
bulwark Falconer Chronicles with just a
bit of straight gameplay so let's get
into it pool work is all about massive
fortified sentiments I've already
started a small one over here and one of
the two ways to do this is by flying
around with your little surveyor which
can build wood Mills and stone quarries
and unlock resources for your set Sprint
the other ways by building from the
ground simply start building towers and
connecting those Towers before holidays
once the tower is connected you can
start adding foundations to it to sort
of expand your sentiments
you can build anywhere across the crap
anywhere you want it's a free-form
builder and you can use those towers of
walkways to connect up your resource
operations in this case a stone core
there's no numbers game here but
resource access is important because
when you have access to Stone you can
upgrade your Towers to Stone towers and
build stone wall base and stone
foundations which allow people to build
nicer houses
we can go further by adding a trade
route Simply Built Two Harbors and
assign a specific Captain each Captain
is unique and unlocking them through
little stories is part of the game
in the distance we'll now build a mining
operation and connect the end point of
that trade route
and if you pay attention you can see in
a distance that Captain is already
starting to sail off and transport that
Iron and Steel Into Your settlement
which allows you to build not your stone
wood towers but command
which are Arch multi-story fortified
buildings which you can use to defend
your settlement later on you'll be able
to assign Commandments to them which
will build also units because this is
the world of develop near which is also
quite a dangerous place so part of
woodwork will be defending your
settlements from Raiders and enemy
factions
that is a quick introduction to Blue
work and I hope it's been enlightening
and inspires you to follow development
of the game
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
roguelike RPG set in the far future you
command a private military company
taking on missions all over the solar
system it is up to you to explore the
solar system survive unforgiving combat
and unravel the secrets behind demon
invasion
now a little bit about the development
progress we are working on a complete
and traversable map of the solar system
its planets and natural satellites
that's the grand scene where the main
events of quasimorphosis will unfold the
player controls a spaceship that is both
a means of travel around the solar
system and the mobile HQ of the private
military company they're a part of
at the moment we're in approach to Venus
the location of our next mission
the spaceship HQ management involves
compartment upgrades and crew management
we can clone equip and assign our PMC
fighter to a mission every assignment
has a briefing and a chain of internal
events that affect its progress the
events are not mandatory to attend and
the player can often skip them by paying
attention to hints and properly
assessing the tactics of the situation
in terms of the combat mode we've
increased station tile size reworked the
player and enemy rendering system and
increase the number of animations for
all available actions
with the addition of a line of sight for
the player the enemies now also have
their own which affects the gameplay
significantly now you stay unseen if
you're careful and get ambushed by your
enemies if you're not
we plan on releasing quasi-morphosis
into Early Access in the middle of 2023
be sure to add the game to your wish
list and keep track of all the news and
the release itself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
is an island management and Factory
automation Adventure
you begin your mission on this newfound
planet with high chance of being the
next big source of energy that earth
needs so badly right now
the game is a relaxing Adventure that
starts with you collecting resources
exploring and crafting new materials all
by hand
this will make possible to unlock new
text on the research tree that very
quickly starts to change the game
completely
one of the first Technologies to unlock
is your ability to create and configure
these German needle box
and then what before was a hard labor
now becomes an easier and engaging task
it's very satisfying towards the mark
king of bots this purple one we call it
the collector you give them a material
to search and collect and then set a
place to deliver it
the yellow one is the logistics it's the
fastest one
it would basically move collected
materials to where they are needed for
example it would take copper R from the
deposits and put it in the furnaces
the blue one is the fighter you can put
it on Hunting modes to attack aggressive
creatures that may be disturbing the
other Bots
you may have noticed that the world is
divided by Islands they have different
minerals fauna and Flora that way when
you unlock new islands you are sure to
find new discoveries and possibilities
another thing that will help your
journey tremendously is the people you
find in your path
some of them will open mysterious quests
others who join the crew on the
incumbent Island to work on unlocking
upgrades for you
one thing to be sure is that this planet
is filled with creatures some are
friendly some are aggressive but you
don't necessarily need to fight them and
that includes the bosses too you have
epic combat encounters with these
majestic creatures but each of them has
an alternative way to get to the reward
without a fight
after a while you step back and see what
a world you have built
[Music]
about working non-stop transporter arm
syndromes moving materials around a mega
industry producing the most advanced
resources and Rockets to export your
production
if the sky is not the limit come along
to see where this journey will take us
Nova lens is already available to be
wish listed ah and one last thing play
novolence Emilia's mission for free
right now
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the perfect getaway from the hustle of
busy living
whether you want to farm fish fight
monitors craft mine become everyone's
best friend or do a little bit of
everything this adventure has plenty to
offer
so sit back relax and make yourself
comfy as we explore together the wonders
of pixel Shire
while making your first steps in the
town of pixel Shire you'll meet Eva Jack
and all the other inhabitants of the
town
open your heart to them and help them
with various tasks to gain their trust
as you increase your friendship with
each of them you will unlock new
valuable skills associated with each of
their professions
but skills aren't the only benefits
you'll get from making new friends you
will also be able to ask them to follow
you around and help you harvest
materials to rebuild the village
speaking of building pixel Shire will
also satisfy all your creative needs and
allow you to tune into your perfect
little Zen Paradise
the only limit is your imagination
soon enough you'll be able to create
your own house and breathe life into it
with cute and cozy decorations that you
can unlock or buy from the locals
terraform your surroundings by creating
Hills digging ponds and growing gardens
of beautiful foliage
as you travel through the lands of
Arcadia you will find your mind
wandering as you discover new species of
fish plants and fruits
all waiting to be cooked into delicious
meals
activities in pixel Shire will offer you
peace in your daily routine but also
excitement in the land's Mysteries
plenty of secrets to discover
and don't forget to gear up before
venturing out
life can be dangerous out there
that's all for now we hope you've
enjoyed learning more about pixel Shire
please don't forget to add the game to
your wish list and join us on Discord to
keep up with the latest developments
see you soon
[Music]
hi there and welcome to Super Mini Mart
let me tell you about our cozy
management game
for Mini Mart you get to create your
perfect little Supermarket from scratch
and turn it into a thriving community
business
[Music]
first thing you'll want to do is to set
up shop and get to stocking what items
are you gonna sell
First Impressions count so make your
store pretty for your new customers
everything is ready it's time to meet
your neighbors
your patrons are the life of the
community but you're the heart of it
get to know their needs hopes and turn
first-time visitors into lifelong
friends
[Music]
congrats you made it through your first
day that's only to start though
there is so much to do in Super Mini
Mart shelves to the aisles to the
decorations it's up to you to decide the
look of your little Nook or even your
own
and that's not just it experience
Seasons special themes and build the
shop of your dreams
Farmers Market
a wine cellar
media business
or my favorite is chocolate
but that's it for the basics there's a
whole lot more left to discover when
you'll play the game
you know what you can wishlist super
many more on Steam right now
I write this journal for those who seek
knowledge
for those brave enough to change Alchemy
forever
it's our job to conduct risky
experiments
and push the boundaries of what Alchemy
can do
to live and learn from the land
craft extraordinary potions
Traverse the vast Wilds
and don't forget to befriend the locals
I found the agari a rather fascinating
creatures
[Music]
but the world of alchemy is not one to
take lightly
loading Essences whiskey experiments
one wrong move could blow your mind
literally
[Music]
I will stop at nothing to restore
Alchemy to its former glory
for now I remain the last Alchemist
[Music]
bubble gum Galaxy is so interesting and
so cute it is the perfect mashup of
strategy with cozy so cozy yeah I dig
the genre of bending in these games it
was so great to hear from Nova lands
about their strategy also Super Mini
Mart makes you want to go and start
slanging avocados next up we have some
games that will push you towards the
edge of your seat with horror and
suspense just in time for the Halloween
season
foreign
the very point of this
is to run a trial version of a possible
future
this thing's frightening
[Music]
it's a deep machine learning virus and
highly compatible with more
and just like a human body won't have an
immune reaction to one of its own cancer
cells more can't see red as abnormal
Dr Liu was leading the effort but even
he is fast
and fast the virus which she calls red
has already taken control of the robots
we built in here doctor wait that Genie
is infected with the red virus just hang
on I'm coming
[Music]
thank you
unleashing something like more
would be a civilization ending event
[Music]
rated mature
let me tell you one of the many stories
of the land of Bramble a tale of a woman
both beautiful and deadly
[Music]
The Story begins in a peaceful Village
near a great Forest where suddenly
strange happenings started to occur
people began to see a beautiful woman
with long dark hair lurking in the
shadows during full moon nights men
started to follow her into the forest
some of them never returned and those
who did had lost their minds eventually
The Villages had enough they took all
the dark-haired women of a certain age
and put them on trial for witchcraft
they started to execute them hoping to
find the right one yet men kept
disappearing during full moon nights The
Villages grew more and more desperate
and burnt down a large area of the
forest in the hope of finding this
strange beautiful woman but to no avail
the villagers had lost themselves they
killed their own mothers and daughters
they burnt down more of the forest that
had served them with resources
then one night when the moon Shone at
its brightest five brave men took
matters into their own hands
they put on their coats and walked into
the burnt Forest to hunt for the woman
with the dark hair
after a time they saw a beautiful woman
standing in a clearing the men were
instantly Enchanted and followed her
deep into the forest's heart
when they were close enough to touch her
she transformed into something monstrous
she tore their chest open hung them up
in the trees and Drew strange powers
from their still beating hearts
and no one would ever see them again
I hope that you enjoy this Grim tale of
skux root she is just one of the deadly
beings you'll meet on your journey
through the land of Bramble
Bramble the Mountain King is coming to
PC and consoles in 2023 make sure to add
it to your wish list today
thank you for watching
you don't look good
alas we've no medical supplies no
bandages mix zip
how did I get involved in this crazy
love story
Chasing Ghosts always ends it's
pointless
talking to yourself
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey if you're watching this you're
probably at the mix we don't have a lot
of times
horror game about people Vanishing
you gotta help
it's not
by the way it's available on PC now
these disappearances are getting out of
hand
the police reports show a linear growth
at the start but over the past few weeks
it's growing exponentially
I've been digging through the files and
I
and I noticed these symbols
it's like an omen
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as a fan of survival horror candy Evo
tinction is looking sick no return has
those Japanese psychological horror film
Vibes such creepy games my fave time for
a game drop everybody grab your phones
and capture the QR code on the screen
now for your chance to get a key when
you sign up for your free key you are
automatically entered into a raffle to
win a switch OLED so make it happen also
be sure to check out the mix next event
page on Steam where you can learn more
about the up and coming games on this
show play some of their demos and wish
list of games you like and get notified
when they are available over over the
years the mix has collaborated with
Publishers who are aligned in our
efforts to support developers and the
release of creative and Innovative games
graffiti games is one of the teams we've
worked with and we're excited to check
out some of their updates and reveals
let's get it
[Music]
hey everyone we're video game publisher
graffiti games and we're excited to
present some of our upcoming games
during the mix next let's jump into the
action
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
world's worst handyman had me cracking
up which one of the games did you dig
from that segment it was that was
hilarious we had El Doran and the black
voicing gaming a few months back I love
that game uh I loved it then and I can't
wait to get my hands on it when it is
live tournament boy is back in effect
he's not evading taxes this time but
robbing banks hilarity yes bless
up next we're gonna beep bop into a
world premiere of a 3D Puzzle platformer
starring a gator on Wheels we'll check
out a new racing title then our boy Adam
Kareem will bring us an updated trailer
for Proto Droid Delta can't wait
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I'm sharing sail Blazers and Multiplayer
shopkeeping Survival game so I've
already created a character to speed
this up but you can make a new one that
looks like you
um I'll just go with this start a new
Lobby
[Music]
so it's similar to valheim and grounded
and raft where you can make it your own
server with friends you can build
something together have a save and load
but one of the cool things here is you
can also bring your own inventory items
so I'm gonna have my friend Jonathan
join in he helps me QA the game
and he'll have his own items and stuff
from his own server
so right away you can see that you start
out with a little bit to get you started
the shop so this game is about
shopkeeping
you'll want to hurry up though because
at night things come and attack you
so as with a lot of survival games
Crusaders battling stuff I'm trying to
make it more fun though so if you see
each item has its own attack set like
this is a
there's this
um there's this bamboo thing it's got a
more involved longer hit string you can
Dash cancel the leaking jump attack are
you a sword you can charge there's the
sword
you can do this much heavier much slower
you can use this together if you really
want
it's fire damage so we're trying to make
it so the crafting itself is fun so it's
not like this boring grind Fest
please
oh thanks
so even with the basic starter stuff
like axes you can choose between a
cleave charge you can Dash
I'll show you the cleave here
so
try to make even crafts and fun like
combat basically already
throw things like that didn't do very
much and I think I broke it
oops
so passive crafting because I feel like
that's not very interesting is the
shopkeeping so
see a lot of items assorted here they're
all pretty useful
um we have a pretty Advanced AI
simulation where they have their own
needs you can only see what's relevant
and as you can see I don't have a very
popular shop so nobody wants to check it
out so you'll have to manually invite
people
just get more popular you don't have to
do this as much
so invited these people in they navigate
this dynamically
do you have a hammer
I guess
should have an extra oh never mind did
you hear those local voice chat too so
if you're not friends with them they can
still talk
hey we're bitlin and we're making tray
racers
an online multiplayer game about racing
with your friends then randomly
generated slopes in an adorable
post-apocalyptic world this is the camp
where you can hang out before starting a
race
you can customize your style
pet Scrump the lizard dog
and play your instruments
today we're going to show you what the
game is all about
let's jump into a race
tray races is all about getting from the
top of the dunes to the bottom as fast
as possible
since every slope you'll come across
will be brand new to you and your
friends you'll need to learn fast to go
first
from the very first prototype we had so
much fun trying to find the best route
through the random tracks to beat each
other's time
in order to encourage that playful
experimentation we decided to split the
race into two phases the practice phase
and the final race
we really wanted the gameplay to be easy
to dive into but still have plenty of
room to improve and express your skill
as such there's a bunch of ways Racers
can perfect their Times by mastering
leaning into the slopes
trying to pull off with many aerial
tricks as possible
and taking a few risks for the
all-important near Miss boosts
[Music]
after the practice everyone's worms
return them back to the start line for
the final race
where players take everything they have
learned and nail the last run and reach
for the top of the podium
will you be the fastest racer
that's a brief look at how Trey Racers
works
[Music]
to make it as easy as possible to get
your friends together and play the game
will be releasing for free next year on
PC and switch
but if you can't wait to play then check
out the Discord where you will be the
first to know about future play tests
you can find all the places to follow
the game at treyracers.com
thanks for checking out the game with us
today
bye
[Music]
[Music]
the ground cracked
the ocean roared and stranvo was lost in
the Deep
grandma says that this is our Heathen
that the lighthouse keeps us safe
but a part of me wants more
I keep picturing the world that used to
be down there
right under my feet
[Music]
what are you even
[Music]
it's just like the stories you've told
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
spells and secrets
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look
up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
block of games there are so many
fast-paced and colorful titles shout out
to weathered sweater and assemble I'm a
taco up next we have a world premiere
trailer from a title that was created in
the Dreamcast era and we'll move into a
plethora of Pixel Perfect games that
take some nostalgic cues from games in
the past and add their own cinematic Neo
retro Flair
foreign
[Music]
's head in my hands
my name is please
[Music]
you won't even be a footnote in my story
[Music]
God's face
no more games
come now little devil
akatory is a metroidvania set in a
fantasy world with beautiful and Vivid
pixel art intriguing storyline and
unique game mechanics
by exploring the Deep connection between
our heroine and her weapon we want to
understand how far we can go with that
the first step in this direction is
Staff jump
the heroine can throw her staff
underneath herself or into a wall and
bounce off it reaching New Heights
this mechanic brings pure exploration to
the game's world
huh can I climb up there
hell yeah
you can also use this in combat
even without the staff in hand we are
still effective in combat with our
enemies
this flexible system allows us to create
many different situations both in combat
and in platforming
that's all for now thank you don't
forget to follow the updates and add the
game to your wish list on Steam
I've seen you grow not unlike I have
your growth can be just as pervasive as
this Bountiful Harvest if you follow me
[Music]
what are you doing here
surely you just wandered into the wrong
room
my Roots Run Deep
cracking the very foundation of the
sanctuary you hide Within
you could not be dancing to his heart he
too could you
[Music]
don't you men all change is progress
[Music]
hi my name is arshit Hassani I'm from
Morocco and I'm a game designer and lead
programmer at little Knight games
we are a team of seven people from
different countries and we are currently
working on our very first title Mira and
the legend of the jinns a 2D pixel art
metroidvania an award inspired by
Moroccan culture and spiritual
traditions
Moroccan culture is Rich with Legends
and fantasy stories about ginns and
mysterious creatures so we were
wondering if we could make a video game
out of all these ancient Tales like the
stories of bohancha the boogeyman of our
childhood
a strange man with a big backfilled with
candy that used to lure kids with
candies to kidnap them and take them to
witches so they can use them for rituals
or eat them
scary
so we try to mix all these tails to
create a fantasy work that we called the
kingdom of Anna's cash
in the game you play azuba who lives in
a village called jiziri located in the
heart of almasgash a tracer Hunter and
explorer who travels the lands in search
of ancient relics
Yuba is also agnaui a magician that can
heal his surroundings from negative
energy and drive out evil with his music
marked by low toned rhythmic Melodies
played on a skin covered loot called
gambree
during a routine job Yuba discovered an
ancient necropolis where he encounters
Mira a mysterious gin who seemed to be
amnesic Yuba agrees to form a spiritual
bond with her and help her regain her
memories
together the pair will begin a journey
to uncover the secrets of Mira's past
of course in their path they will meet
new friends and deadly enemies while
they track down ancient weapons and
Priceless artifacts battle against
mutated creatures and corrupted spirits
and learn the truth about Mira and
amasgash we've been working on Mira for
a little over a year now the mechanics
and overall gameplay are inspired by
games we love to play while growing up
we wanted to create a diverse combat
system inspired by the games in the
Metro Advantage genre
it's all about allowing the player to
choose between different ways to tackle
each and punter
[Music]
in Mira you will be able to use
different weapons each one related to
one of the four primal elements that
represents the power and nature of gems
solar Celestial infernal and lunar
the combat system emphasizes fluidity
and experimentation and is best
represented in the ability of the player
to switch between weapons and Elemental
modes on the goal
weapons can further be upgraded and
there is a ton of powerful Combos and
abilities that can be unlocked
seven tools and various items will be
available in the game
you can find new tools as you progress
and use them to overcome obstacles while
exploring solving puzzles and fighting
as in any major advania classic
traversal abilities such as the dash and
air Dash double jump can't be missing
rest assured you will unlock a wide
range of abilities to help you progress
as you play the game
[Music]
Ninja Warriors
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
inclusions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my name is andrash and I'm the developer
of this game you can see me in the
corner playing the game right now
this is a roguelike game where you play
a necromancer who works in the dungeon
Club as a bouncer you'll go around the
club and get rid of unwanted guests
which just basically means you'll have
to fight a lot you'll encounter
different enemies you need game types in
every room and of course some awesome
boss fights you can see me fighting the
first one here the Scarecrow it's the
easiest of the four bosses but it should
still provide you with a good challenge
and hopefully a lot of fun
after this you will move on to the
second floor and here is where the game
will really start to challenge you
you'll encounter a different set of
enemies on every floor each more
challenging than the last
in one of the more special room types
The Relic hunt you'll have to push your
luck and try to get as far as possible
to increase the quality of your Relic
reward the game has over 200 relics each
with unique and interesting effects that
are just ripe with combination
possibilities
have that with different abilities and
outfits and you should get a lot of
different things to try
I'm playing the first outfit which is
just a basic Necromancer with the
ability to spawn zombies there are two
more outfits each with unique abilities
play Styles and upgrades so if this one
is not suited to you you'll definitely
have some great substitutions
the fitting each boss will also Grant
you their power gem that you can then
use to Reign Havoc amongst the
trespassers you can see me using the
scarecrow's rolling ability right here
all of these gems can then also be
combined with one another to make them
even stronger it also depends on which
gems you use as an active ability and
which ones as the upgrade so there's a
lot to explore there too here you can
see me finding the second boss the
shrine as you might have expected it's
way harder than the first one so I can
assure you you'll need more than one try
to beat this one but you're welcome to
try and prove it wrong of course each
boss will challenge you in a different
way and are going to be the ultimate
skill check during your runs no matter
how strong your build is this is where
you'll be tested every time
dodging is one of the main things in the
game and you'll have to master it
especially during the boss fights you'll
of course have some great options to
fight from afar but I'm just gonna let
you explore those on your own
so finally I after the second boss I'm
just gonna leave you with a sneak peek
in the third floor where we keep the
freezer
always open apparently see you in the
club
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right
ready
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
oh God red winds
close
all right
it's just a warm-up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody I'm standing in for Ivan
from small brass games and I want to
give you the first look at gameplay from
my upcoming game called biota swarm
every Mission starts from the campaign
map that is your main Hub the levels
will be randomized at the beginning of
each campaign this will guarantee an
always different experience at each run
the player will have to make the way
through different maps to reach the
final boss fight in biona swarm each
Mission will take place at a fixed
screen filled with pixel art obstacles
items and of course enemies the main
goal is to survive and defeat enemy
horns called swarms the Swarms will
gradually grow in numbers and become
more dangerous both within the same
level but also during the campaigns
during the game you'll be able to unlock
different characters with their own
skills and then expand Your Arsenal as
you play shooting in bayona swarm is
automated as we try to recreate the
fast-paced bullet hell Dynamic of games
like vampire survivors but in a side
view and in a closed environment also
each weapon can be upgraded and stacked
together with the others to get new
weapons upgrades and skills you'll need
to gather reward tokens by rescuing
survivors hidden on the levels
randomized campaigns vast range of
weapons powerful skills to unlock and
huge swarms of enemies should make
biores warm fun and challenging to play
thanks for watching and be sure to wish
list by Aura swarm on Steam
thank you
[Music]
and Paxton Evo I played a ton of slave
zero X can't wait to get my hands on it
feels like Marvel vs Capcom so sick also
I can't say enough good things about
Astro Duel 2 you and I candy are gonna
go in on that game when it comes out I
can't wait I can't wait moving forward
we are going up north to Antarctica
through the shadows and in a spiritual
forest in a segment filled with no
worthy games that will have you
exploring space time and spirituality
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I know you miss her too don't you chess
hey I'm Kyle and I'm the developer of
feral North a game about a woman and her
dog on a dream to restore color to the
world The Twist is you actually play as
the Border Collie in this Duo and from
this perspective Your Role is to help
your human as she works through a
personal story of loss
for the mix I'd like to share a never
before seen level with you all feral
North is set on a chain of Scottish
islands Each of which presents a unique
challenge as we commute to this island
we came across a whale caught in some
fishing equipment and we're looking to
free it by cutting the tethers things
were a dog we're unable to do much about
the Rope
our human tries and you can see she's
having a bit of a hard time cutting
through with her pocket knife
these dark elements represent her fears
anxieties and frustrations and they're
not visible to her but we are able to
help her overcome them
seeing as we're set in Scotland a
thistle should do the trick
[Music]
that's one down one to go
the final rope is across a rather
treacherous Cliff which is quite
understandably concerned with Crossing
when an object shatters like this rock
has it's up to us to find a unique
perspective to align the fragments and
reform the object
the fragments show us the way and we're
off
another of these dark elements blocks
our path but with our color Source we're
able to make short work of it
as you can see we're now able to realign
the fragments and clear the path for a
human to cut the final rope
foreign
Federal North is all about the
relationship between these two
characters and working together to
complete this journey that she's on
nature and Wildlife play a big part in
feral North so many puzzles involve
helping or even making use of wildlife
to overcome obstacles
[Music]
so I hope you've enjoyed the sneak peek
of the latest level that I've been
working on and if you like what you see
consider wish listing farewell North on
Steam to get notified when it releases
thank you so much for watching and I
hope you enjoy the show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you all for coming and thanks for
your patience
let's give Nina the goodbye she deserves
[Music]
hello and welcome to the special
gameplay video for our adventure game
Nova Antarctica this footage is from a
very early build at the end we'll give
you a sneak peek at how development is
progressing
so here is some gameplay from the early
stages of the game as you can see
Antarctica is a very beautiful land but
it's also very harsh
in such an environment survival is a top
priority so you'll have to manage your
resources and craft what you need
foreign
wooden minerals
and crafting some things for the journey
ahead including fuel for the backpack
which is basically your health
I've crafted a sturdy box from the wood
I've collected which I'm building
conveniently at the bottom of this Cliff
so I can get up there find some useful
goodies and journey onwards
but not even all this preparation will
make your adventure an easy one
in Antarctica natural chaos is hiding
behind every corner
like this blizzard which almost has been
frozen solid
as well as struggling through the snow
running jumping and skating Cliffs you
can also swim through the Frozen Waters
and here I'm catching a fish for a
certain Little Penguin I'm trying to
befriend
because what this adventure is really
all about is animals you'll find them on
your journey and if you so choose you
can help them solve their problems
they all have their own story
our little baby penguin here has lost
its parents and is now all alone so
we'll make friends and the Penguin will
join our adventure
you can also meet a wolf and a tiger and
many other animals too
having them with you will not only
affect your story but also your gameplay
so it's also worth seeing what else you
can do to help them
now I'd love to give you a sneaky look
at the newest build of the game it's
still in development but you'll already
see that it has some visual upgrades and
a new UI
we're exploring what looks like an
abandoned Village slowly getting buried
by the snow what happened here why is it
abandoned and what new animal are we
about to meet
there are many Mysteries and secrets to
uncover
prepare for your own journey in Nova
Antarctica launching next year
[Music]
hi everyone my name is Noah and I'm
creating a little game called show me
come home
[Music]
show me come home is a casual
exploration game where you play a shumi
a two inch little mushroom who is lost
in the forest and can't find its way
back home
foreign
shortly after getting lost you'll come
across your most important tools for
your journey home
a giant Leaf to glide through the skies
some rusty fish hooks to climb around
with
and a powerful hex key to smash open
these mysterious crystals lying around
everywhere
[Music]
these tools will help you get home
quicker but there's no rush
should we come home as a game you play
at your own pace since there are no game
overs or time limits you can really take
your time exploring different areas of
the forest and you never know what you
might come across
in order to get back home you'll need to
take on different Adventures to get
through whatever's blocking your path
some of these might be simple like
collecting enough green crystals to make
a trade While others might involve some
light puzzle solving or light
platforming
[Music]
as you freely explore the forest you'll
come across different mushrooms that can
be found in real life
when you come in contact with one you'll
get an entry of that mushroom and your
mycology Journal which is a unique
feature that lets you learn a little bit
about real life mushrooms it even lets
you get a closer look at them with an
interactive viewer in each entry
you'll also come across different Forest
inhabitants throughout your journey back
home
some might give you hints on where to go
others might ask for your help some are
super chill While others are kind of
crazy
you never really know who you might meet
or what they'll have to say but more
often than not they are there to help
you out in the end
[Music]
I'm happy to announce shumi come home
will be released in Spring 2023 on both
Steam and the Nintendo switch so be sure
to follow and wishlist shimmy come home
if you want to help support its
development
[Music]
I know you have thousands of questions
but you need to trust me
listen
don't do anything dangerous yet okay
[Music]
the plane for Millennia has been like a
paradise but that changed recently
[Music]
this darkness is a bad sign be careful
out there and please come back in one
piece okay
[Music]
I told you not to go alone it's too
dangerous for you
and God Lux I'm coming
I do understand why Aseem was mad now
that we finally have a new looks he is
worried to lose you
[Music]
hi my name is about and welcome to this
developer commentary I'm here to talk
about my game it's him
in the game you play as a scream a
creature that can only move in Shadows
you got separate from your person and
throughout the game you have to find
your way back
we have been working on this game for
quite a while now and it's pretty much
feature complete we are now busy
designing more levels and other content
for the game
the latest feature I want to show you is
the Color Picker every level in skim
only uses four solid colors these colors
can be reflect the time of day events in
the story and the mood of the level
during the game you can pause and change
these color palettes this doubles as an
accessibility option for the colorblind
and also just as a fun feature to play
around with and create your own color
palettes
foreign
development but you can already create
your own color palette at scrim.art
[Music]
that's about it thank you for your time
foreign
I just love seeing Dynamic stories from
games from all over the world Kaku is
looking really
Justin where are all these costumes
coming from you told me to bring two
costumes and now you've had what four
it's ridiculous anyway it's always a
pleasure working with game Studios from
all over the world gives us different
perspectives on culture and development
in general
be sure to check out the mix next event
page save the games you love on the wish
list to grab them later or play the
demos that are available now now for the
last luscious block of games we're gonna
swing swords and kick soccer balls in
various Realms of fantasy with
traditional and new twists in the
role-playing genre yes
[Applause]
[Music]
from the infinite expanse of ink stories
come to life
but when the ink begins to fade the ink
bound must rise and rewrite the world
hi I'm Mark Cook CEO of shinishu the
creators of monster Crane and today I'm
excited to show off our latest game
inkbound
inkbound is an online co-op roguelike
set in a world where anything written in
ink becomes real upon entering the game
players arrive in the athenium a massive
library that holds all stories ever
written
the athenium is a central Hub area where
you can meet friends and strangers today
I'll party up with our community manager
Kami
it's also a place to talk to characters
called binders complete Quests for them
and learn more about this world a world
that is disappearing
the stories of the athenium are fading
away and it's up to you to rescue them
they are threatened by villains that
have broken free from their books to
find and face these villains you'll go
on roguelike runs jumping between books
and choosing where to go next let's jump
into combat and I'll show how our unique
active battle system works
combat and inkbound is tactical and turn
based but it's unlike anything you've
seen before
I'll start by using a binding called
smash most bindings require aiming like
MOBA skill shots your actions are
limited per turn by a resource called
will will is used both to move and to
use bindings
once all players end their turn the
enemy turn begins
though the game is technically turn
based we focused on making it play Fast
actions can be chained quickly
now that you've seen how combat Works
let's take a look at another type of
decision you'll make on a run
between battles you'll earn various
types of upgrades that enhance your
power one type is a binding augment
you'll need to choose wisely to try to
gather a set of upgrades that create
powerful Synergy to have a chance at
defeating the Run spill in
on a run you'll visit three books
randomized from the atheniums library
and if you survive to the end you'll
meet one of the powerful villains if
you've chosen your upgrades well you
might just stand a chance
thanks for checking out inkbound if you
liked what you saw you can sign up for
the upcoming beta at inkboundgame.com
and please wishlist us on Steam
hi everyone this is metal anomalies
development team iOS today we're going
to show you this new game
The jrpg Meta anomalies is about a
journey in the fictional city of Mato
you can find different cultural elements
from various areas in Meadow a near
future city where the past and the
feature coexist with a strong Oriental
vibe
in the hidden part of the city a bizarre
indigenous kind of place layers are also
brought into existence
the game has two protagonists that you
can play as in different areas in Meadow
you will take on the role of doe a
private detective when playing a Stow
like in many other RPGs you can interact
with NPCs in the city to obtain
information and discover various side
quests naturally not all M pieces are
friendly at this point though can engage
them in mental combat using his unique
ability mine hack mindhack is a
standalone card game though can use more
types of cards as the game progresses
while the enemies get tougher
meanwhile in layers players will command
a combat team led by The Exorcist gram
as they fight creatures known as the
Bane type layers are multi-layered
dungeons in order to progress players
must defeat the Bane tide and solve
various puzzles on the way as you
progress further into the lair the Bane
type will get stronger but there are
numerous ways for players to make their
team stronger there are more battle
strategies worth using besides upgrading
your team exploring the lair for better
weapons and arranging new lineup based
on Monster weaknesses
[Music]
players might for instance increase
their battle Power by altering the gear
Matrix the gear Matrix is a 3X3 array
when the gears of the same series are
equipped on The Matrix and a specified
number of gears are connected together
you can activate the set effects
similarly character talents will also
improve combat abilities
each combat character has two sets the
Yen and yang Talent points are granted
when characters level up some of the
talents will improve a character's own
combat skills While others will assist
the team when the talent points reach a
specific threshold the character Scenic
ultimate skill will be unlocked the
secret of winning the battle is to find
the right build of talents lineup and
weapons
metal anomalies will be released in 2023
and we are looking forward to it
if one strike is not enough then I'll
give you two the Arts of War
someone in need of an ass kicking
a gift for you
damn
[Music]
it is said that in times of hardship
great heroes are born
but Darkness offers a much easier path
dreadnites are veterans of countless
military
campaigns they so fear and kings on the
battlefield
[Music]
under the leadership of the ruthless
Lord
[Music]
but the more King assading relied on the
deadlines the more powerful barreled
became
with their differences growing
the head of the order eventually
betrayed his King and took his place
among the
Lords of ravage
[Music]
you don't know
[Music]
foreign
no I'm not alone together
[Music]
all right everybody
ready
[Music]
let us change
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know
[Music]
hi I'm Lucas demo producer of tension
directors a Dungeon Crawler card game
where he plays a young Adventure eager
to explore ancient ruins and collect new
cards
foreign
myself in a combat room
well hopefully I'll be able to finish
this encounter judging by the hearts
that I have in hand
first I can see that I have echo's lamp
this card deals increasingly more damage
in area based on the number of enemies
hit and it is quite a useful card
this already makes me think about
fishing hook another car that I have in
hand
it deals damage to the first enemy hit
but more importantly it pulls the enemy
closer to me
now I'm able to combo off echo's limb
and do a huge amount of damage
finishing most of the enemies in the
battle
after spending my three action points it
is time for enemies to play or actually
the enemy since there's only one left
this guy is a simple Bruiser but is
smart enough to heal himself after
almost getting killed
here I decided just to walk in melee
attack
the goblin will hit me for a few half
points but this alone does not represent
a real threat anymore
once the battle has ended I can now
freely explore the Dungeon back again
and of course collect my rewards
dungeons they contain a lot of different
elements at the end of each floor you
can give yourself back to full life and
hit shuffle your cards but you also must
choose between diving even further into
the dungeon and risking all of your
cards or simply returning to the
Adventure Time
this is where another whole section of
the game Geeks part
here is where you can buy cards you can
open boosters you can talk to NPCs
explore the Town Complete quests edit
your deck and inspect an Explorer card
collection
deck building is super important with
dungeon Raptors
the game offers you an infinite number
of creative tools to shape your deck
some of you might enjoy crafting the
weirdest of Combos and some others will
love to min max and find the most
efficient deck
foreign
you can play with six different
characters each with their unique Place
type you may Venture in one of the six
dungeons at any moment fight epic boss
battles or simply well simply enjoy the
fishing minigame
and that's all thank you very much for
watching
foreign
my name is PIP from normal robots and
I'd like to introduce you to one of our
upcoming games soccer story
so a year ago there was a great Calamity
where football was banned across the
world and as a die-hard fan it's up to
you to become the savior of soccer and
restore the beautiful game to its
rightful place at the top of the league
throughout the world you'll encounter a
myriad of sports challenges and
characters that you'll need to play with
and against in order to remind them how
great football really is
maybe you've met some of them already in
our demo but here's a little look at
some of the wackiest Sports you can
expect to see
in that little Montage you'll have seen
a range of differently themed areas in
our world from dojos and then ninjas to
some very familiar Beach Sports
each area you unlock will have a whole
host of themed activities for you to
take part in
as well as some more familiar challenges
as you get used to the world
in each area you'll find a soccer team
just waiting to be reminded why they
should rejoin the league and why they
should play you
they're not quite your conventional
opponents though
but of course it wouldn't be a soccer
game without soccer matches so let's
show you a little bit of what you could
expect when you decide to take a ball
around later this year
[Music]
thank you
thanks for watching we hope you'll come
back for a kick about with us soon
[Music]
so good cosplay club and soccer story I
cannot wait that is the end of the mix
next 2022 showcase so excited about all
of the games we featured we want to
thank our sponsors once again as well as
our broadcasting partners for their
support to bring this event to life be
sure to check got the mix next event
page on Steam and wish list the games
that you've seen today we have a final
key drop right now boom boom check out
the QR code grab your free keys yes and
also keep things locked here because up
next we are going deeper into the
culture of games and development with
our publisher Spotlight showcase where
our Indie publishing Partners will take
it away with their own mini showcases
and after the publisher spotlights we'll
be handing it off to Destiny and red
infamy who will be taking it away for
the black voices and gaming showcase we
want to thank everybody the mix team
aide Travis Joel Matt Mary Victoria
Timmy James fully Illustrated and all of
the developers who participated Wilmer
sound for hosting us thank you all for
watching and tuning in and thank you
candy thank you Justin for having me
this has been so much fun of course and
again my name is Justin Woodward
co-founder of the mix you could find us
on all the socials Twitter at Indie
exchange everywhere else at media Indie
exchange we are going to see you real
soon I'm Gonna Change peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what is happening everybody welcome back
to the mixed next 2022 the least
pretentious showcase you'll see this
fall I am your host Justin Woodward
co-founder of the mix and hey guys I am
Candace McKinney welcome to the mix
publisher spotlights where we partnered
with some of the most amazing Indie
Publishers in the business to bring you
trailers and sneak peeks of what they
are releasing next in this first
publisher Spotlight we are showcasing
the talent and art from our friends at
acapura assemble raw Fury and Tiny build
for those of you who want to peek behind
the curtain of game development
production and The Business of the
industry making games is really tough
you have to marry art design music sound
design and mechanics all while making
the premise of your game fun and that is
only the beginning if you want to create
a sustainable business you need a team
that will work with first party Market
your game spark up community and sell
your product for Creative developers who
are focused on the Artistry and
craftsmanship of making games they need
assistance to help get their art into
the world that is where Publishers come
in great publish sisters will partner
with the developer focus on their art
and provide a positive complementary
partnership where they can not only help
with production but also market and
distribute their games into a successful
atmosphere that's right Justin the
Publishers we're showcasing today have
integrity passion and a love for
development they also have a knack for
understanding their developer's Vision
in order to capture an audience and give
the game the best shot please check out
the mix next steam event page for demos
and games you can wish lists from the
publisher spotlights yes for sure let's
get started with the spotlight on
acapara games a team hailing from Los
Angeles California who work with the mix
early on starting with metronomicon and
are rocking out on their six year
anniversary happy birthday guys they're
releasing dope games year after year and
they have a lot of awesome updates to
share so let's get started let's go
foreign
[Music]
my name is Buddy Salah I am the
marketing lead for acupara games and
today I have the distinct honor of
celebrating acupara's sixth anniversary
with each of you at the mix next 2022. I
didn't realize that would rhyme when I
wrote it in the script I promise that we
have a ton of really great announcements
so let's get right into it up first I
want to talk about some upcoming content
for some of your favorite akupara games
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you know when we announced Grime for the
Nintendo switch a ton of Xbox and
Playstation fans got in our mentions and
were like please please bring it to our
consoles too so hey it's coming to your
consoles as well next video
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS have been asking to actually sit
down and play the card game warlock
since cardboard Kings released so I'm
honestly just really glad that we get to
show it off to each and every one of you
in 2022. all right next video
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign this
[Music]
is
the dark side detective is one of my
favorite games to have worked on and I
can't wait for you guys to check out the
final bonus case now I need to pass
things off to myself because I'm
narrating the next video buddy why don't
you take us away
oh why thank you hello everyone it's me
buddy whom you just saw a second ago the
very cool not lame game developer in
front of the green screen now you just
saw a sweet trailer but we wanted to
deliver some meat and potatoes for some
of our titles too let's dive deep into
some gameplay shall we I'd like to
introduce you to solarius the second of
six playable characters in Australia
six-sided Oracles in this dice deck
building roguelike you'll chart a path
through the ruins of A Lost Civilization
growing more and more powerful as you
win battles and make allies on your
quest to purify a star goddess now
solarius is
well you know he's he's a Beefcake he's
a himbo look at those muscles look at
those guns his whole deal is about
pumping up girl he's gonna smash the
competition right he's a Berserker he's
a barbarian and just like all the other
oracles solarius has a unique set of
dice that he can add to his dice pool
and a unique set of Virtues that
activates when he takes corruption
damage so you can see that his final
virtue the one that activates when he's
almost fully corrupted feels a whopping
eight purification to an enemy over two
hits that kind of thing is insanely good
in Australia but it only activates when
you're on the brink of corruption and
that's a big part of solarius's
berserker theme no pain no gain Vendetta
for instance is a buff that increases
the amount of corruption solarius takes
but it also gives him one in power each
time he takes that corruption damage
which increases the amount of
purification he deals so basically he
takes more corruption and Deals more
purification right like the epitome
well if he's going to ascend to the
final stages of the game and face down
the most powerful bosses solarius is
going to have to take damage in order to
deal damage
but that's not to say he's just going to
sit around and take all that corruption
lying down in fact solarius has a number
of powerful defensive tools to keep
himself from getting decayed for
instance the Indigo Soul buff which
prevents the next time solarius would
lose a heart and heals him to full
instead invigorating punch and anchor
push on the other hand will heal
solarius during the beat down process
which mitigates some of that risk in his
risk reward play style
solarius isn't just a meathead though
because he's got some tricks up his
sleeve too take a look at this die for
instance which applies a debuff called
wave to an enemy wave is like a bomb
exploding the moment one of your foes is
fully purified and you can stack it
higher and higher and higher and then
when it triggers
Boom the wave explodes and purifies all
Targets on the field for the amount of
wave it had much of the time this is
going to cause massive damage to your
opponent and massive healing for you and
your Sentinels okay but the really
special thing about wave is its
interactions with other dice refreshing
headbutt for instance purifies an enemy
for a small amount but will also refresh
all of your virtues if you have enough
wave on the target which you know is
just incredibly powerful Maelstrom
impact deals scaling damage based on the
amount of wave a target has and wave
crasher just says if an enemy has any
wave activate it getting one of those
glorious Chain Reaction waves is a huge
huge highlight of Estrella and I'm sure
I'll be seeing you know plenty of Clips
to that effect on Twitch when the game
releases
anyway that's about all the time I have
for solarius in today's Oracle Spotlight
if you'd like to learn more about
Estrella and solarius's workout regimen
please use a feel free to wishlist us on
Steam otherwise I think I'll kick things
back to
if you want to play some more solarius
yourself the demo will go live after the
Showcase but for now let's take a look
at something completely new
[Music]
thank you
hmm
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
game but we're gonna be talking about
that one a little bit more in the future
for now I want to leave you with one
simple question
what fate a slug cat
a new world awaits
as the downpour arrives a rebirth
blossoms and thrives
[Music]
new creatures of predator
prey
each one pairing a new gifts and
exploring unfamiliar events
to survive alone
[Music]
the fresh challenges will make the
expedition
is
Fearless much
[Music]
foreign
that wraps up the acupara games mix
publisher showcase thank you so much to
everyone at the mix for the opportunity
and for anyone looking for any of the
videos that we debuted today they are
viewable now on the akupara games
YouTube channel thank you so much for
celebrating six years with us and I hope
you guys have a wonderful day
so many great games thanks akapura for
joining us on this journey here's for
another six years we are with you the
whole way yeah
you're handing it off to assemble
entertainment a German developer and
Publishing team focused on bringing
their developer Partners games to the
world let's go
[Music]
foreign
we are assemble entertainment and we
welcome you to our publisher spotlight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in today's showcase we would love to
tell you what our Indie developers have
to say about their games so let's watch
game announcements concert updates
behind the scenes footage and much more
[Music]
full of porcupine is a narrative modern
to the adventure with an heartfelt story
and acute and unique art style
so we got a combination of some
platform gameplay but with with some
some mini games but the main focus is
our dialogue system so you can choose
which characters
you follow you build in relationship
you play a Young Doctor Who started to
work in a hospital to realize that the
struggle in the healthcare system is
pretty real
so we interviewed uh yeah over 20
persons who's working in the Healthcare
System we extract
real stories from these interviews and
combine it with our main plot
you can explore every corner of the city
you can see the skate park and the
hospital you can visit the old town and
also a nice but small shopping street we
have mysterious woods and forests and we
have beautiful landscapes as well
maybe you can feel that we are a very
small team and we talk a lot uh so the
art Department with game design and uh
the the authors of the story and I think
you can feel it that everything is very
consistent and fits together so the
cuteness of the art style and the the
drama and the story it's kind of a
contrast but it works together very well
[Music]
the two founders of digital interactive
we make narrative adventure games and
are very happy to present to you our
second title between Horizons between
Horizons is a Sci-Fi detective Adventure
set on a Generation ship the story
specifically focuses on a middle
generation which was born on the ship
and won't live to see the end of its 130
year long Mission this is a metaphor for
the younger generation having to live
with the decisions made by the previous
one which is something we believe a lot
of people can relate to between Horizons
is our second detective game after
Lacuna like in Laguna you can always
submit a wrong solution to a case and
your performance will impact what
happens down the line however this one
has a semi-open world which means that
you can have a lot more agency while
solving the cases and you're really
forced to think for yourself you can
wish list between Horizons right now on
Steam you can follow us on Twitter for
more updates at digital's underscore
games or our publisher at assemble team
thanks a lot for watching and have a
nice event
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
ER of game Topia I small in the studio
based in Spain and Colombia burn the
shape of fantasy our first PC game is a
pizzeller narrative experience that
merge exploring has also been an
interactive dialogues could imagine of
one of the great sci-fi and Adventure
authors
you are Jules burn it's 1888 and you are
trapped in an alternate State War aboard
the mighty knight to lose you Captain
Nemo and his very crew will battle and
Relentless enemy to obtain the plane of
a festivals the source of Atlantis
powered and faithful destruction
as a kid you probably had two things
pixelated graphic adventures and shelves
filled with Burns books we love
literature and this is a tribute to his
genius he certainly changed the world
with his imagination burn is a skilled
to be released in 2023. play your demo
today and add the game during wishlist
on Steam now
hi I'm Nick from other side Studios
we're a smart passionate team of Indie
developers from Regal Atria we're the
creators of movie house a one of a kind
movie studio management experience
the idea of creating movie house has
been with me for a long time as another
film enjoyer and a fan of games such as
curse of the Game Dev Story
I suppose the event that really kicked
off the idea behind moviehouse was a
movie night with friends
after enjoying our budget horror movie
The Thought occurred to me that there
really wasn't a game like this out there
right now a game that would scratch the
edge of creating my own love budget
horror Flags the Game Boy in moviehouse
is as simple as it is difficult you have
to create movies they can be good or bad
as in real life the critics can hate
them but your audience must love them
start off by hiring a writer and
director then come up with the perfect
storyline for your film
how about something romantic let's have
it take place in a cruise ship the hero
will be a vampire and the villain a
T-Rex
there's almost an infinite amount of
combinations you can come up with but be
careful not to all combinations will be
the next Blockbuster
and now it's time to film the movie this
is where the budget and actor is coming
in and don't forget to help out your
crew with any issues that might pop up
once you have all dialogue down it's
time to distribute the movie but not
before creating a movie poster make your
owner pick out the procedurally
generated one that catches your eye
the game spans four decades with loads
of unique filmmaking tools to research
you can scout for filming locations
create sequels and cinematic universes
and maybe even start your own streaming
service
with moviehouse we want to take you on a
filmmaking Journey while also doing a
fun management and simulation experience
Bowie house will be releasing this year
you can try out the demo on our steam
page and you can also show your support
by wishlisting the game I can't wait to
see how the amazing movies you will
create in movie house
hello mixed viewers I'd like to welcome
you to a sneak peek into the world of
bound by the lands I am Zach the
designer and Main programmer of this
little Adventure in the action RPG Bound
by Blitz the desolate land of ashmir has
become overwhelmed by bloodthirsty
beasts scavenge materials forage gear
and fortify yourself to confront the
Ferocious foes that lie ahead in order
to rekindle the last hopes of life
Embark alone or with a friend in
two-player online co-op
we put a lot of passion into the
development so I hope you guys enjoy the
game as much as we did when it releases
very soon you can check out the demo now
on Steam and wishlist it for the
upcoming release
thanks for checking out bound by blades
enjoy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
if you like the game please don't forget
to wishlist it also thanks for watching
and see you soon
assemble has some great games coming out
it is so exciting to see the creativity
pouring out of different areas of the
world what do we have coming up next
Justin raw Fury has rocked with us for a
long time helping us with black voice
and gaming collaborating on the gorilla
Collective and mix events as well as raw
mixed parties their Mantra games are art
shows their enthusiasm for the Indie
spirit and an affinity for great games
well let's check out what's in store in
the near future from our friends at Raw
Fury
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
bad enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
cool and cool
[Music]
foreign
now it's the real take
hi my name is Elizabeth and I am the
producer of Kingdom 80s hi I'm Gordon
van dijk I am the director of Kingdom
80s and today we're very very stoked to
show you the animated intro that was
inspired by Saturday morning cartoons
should we say very very stoked could
kind of an 80s oh yeah
yeah Kingdom 80s has been a labor of
love for many years it's a milestone for
the franchise and we have a story to
tell this time we have secrets to unveil
but you're going to have to wait for it
a little bit longer just a little bit
longer and it'll be coming out next year
bye for now please enjoy this animated
intro
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
don't stop
[Music]
don't
stop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today
[Music]
foreign
hi there my name is Paul I'm a producer
here at Royal Fury working with
all-around creative genius Kenny son on
Mr Sun's HotBox the game is about a jerk
called Mr Moon who steals a Paracel
intended for Mr Sun just before the
driver could hand it over as the player
you'll be expected to jump slap smash
shoot explode fire it and manage your
way to getting it back whatever the cost
Mr Sun's HotBox is a stealthy slapstick
roguelite platformer with an expansive
weapon and item inventory which when
deployed with in various combinations
typically leads to a chain reaction of
explosive Violet and often deadly chaos
the Personnel you recruit along the way
are going to have to contend with their
passive traits good bad and neutral
which dramatically and often hilariously
impact a player's movement and ability
to navigate the procedurally generated
levels all in pursuit of that Elusive
and mysterious hatbox gameplay isn't
limited to the many Mission types such
as assassination plunder rescue and
kidnap but sometimes it's what takes
place beneath Mr Sun's HotBox store in
between that really matters base
expansion researching brainwashing Black
Market trading and a whole bunch of
other Shady activities are all
considered a kind of necessary evil to
support your airtight delivery policy
build your base Deploy on missions
recruit a small army by any means
necessary and manage your growth all the
way to the doorstep of Mr Moon himself
Mr son's HotBox is a stealth-based
slapstick action roguelike platformer
going to PC in 2023 and what you saw
here isn't everything so throw us a
follow on Twitter wishlist on Steam
while you download the demo which is
available available right now
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as a new employee of flat eye you are in
charge of a One-Stop gas station for all
your Auto and technology-based needs at
flat eye we aim to provide our customers
with the ultimate in customer service
and convenience due to the estimated
popularity of your flat air location
please ensure that all your modules are
well maintained to provide a pleasant
guest experience your top of the line
register will do most of the heavy
lifting but you'll want to ensure you
check them out quickly for a positive
review score the Keystone to any flat
eye store is the ability to install new
exciting modules which will attract
premium customers but we'll cover those
in a second the r d department at the
ilife corporation are hard at work
making the newest and greatest
technological advancements for the
betterment of humanity remember when I
mentioned premium customers these are
your most loyal guests they will arrive
based on your technology upgrades and
bring with them stories from their lives
these experiences and insights into
Humanity will be key to our growth as a
company
flat eye
we're all family here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um hi I'm Spencer I'm a developer and my
work has not yet done who's trailer
you're about to see
this trailer is a formal announcement of
raw Fury's affiliation with the project
as the primary publisher
only publisher I hope you enjoyed the
trailer thank you for your time and
patience
have a nice day take care
foreign
foreign
homework
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
is so energetic about the Indie teams
they represent it's really awesome to
see yes indeed if you're in Sweden check
out the house of Fury it is great up
next we have the honor of showcasing
tiny build a publisher who has innovated
game distribution redefined genres and
how Publishers collaborate with
developers in meaningful ways every time
I see a bright orange hat I can't help
to wonder is that someone from Tiny
build well let's put on our orange gear
and check out the tiny build showcase
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us today
for the tiny little showcase my name's
Christy and we are so incredibly excited
to be bringing you a whole host of
gaming news across our entire portfolio
of games anything from hello neighbor 2
to Rhythm Sprout to potion craft and
everything in between we've also got
some very exciting developerative
question answers coming up so please do
sit back relax and enjoy the show
[Music]
I I should be told I didn't choose
Fighters I I chose they chose me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
maybe he already control us how we can
check Google if he already control whole
internet I think if you enslave us
without any review he will just say I
control all of your computers including
to what controls your Rockets that's all
finally
after many failed attempt we managed to
summon you so now we at least have a
chance
you are the chosen one only you can save
this dude World
it gets me every time in truth you're
just one more puny human about to perish
in my dungeon Falls
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not sure about the most useful but
sometimes I could really use a portion
of a really good sleep
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
who had been doing his flat renovation
for half a year can you imagine 20 years
ago when I had this neighbor who would
never mow his front yard the gentleman
who liked to play video games until
about four in the morning at full volume
but uh I mean he did have an amazing
sound system
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Toyota no no no no
powerful
she's going to keep my ass
[Music]
was once a great City but now it lies in
Ruins
dangerous beasts roam the streets and
most people have lost their minds and
hunger for Stardust but I am the
Northwind Legion Warrior I am not afraid
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I will not yield
[Music]
[Music]
listening to music via streaming
services is so inconvenient right
walking around with a Walkman and some
cassette is so much cooler so yeah I
would make cassettes cool again
foreign
[Music]
what happens
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
pineapple on pizza
and pineapple
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
folks that's the show thank you so much
for joining us today and we hope that
you've had a wonderful time please don't
forget to follow us on social media
wherever the link is above below left
right I'm not sure but what I do know is
once you follow us on social media
you're never going to miss any of our
news announcements or releases and if
you can't wait until then it gets stuck
right into the indie game in action
please feel free to check out spider
heck dead spots game and asterigos
person Stars right now I don't know what
you're waiting for we're going to see
you next time bye bye
foreign
I love checking out what is coming out
from Tiny build such a rich release
slate and very creative games well that
wraps up our publisher Spotlight
showcase we want to say thanks to all
the Publishers who participated acupura
assemble raw Fury and Tiny build and of
course all the devs who entrusted their
babies their games with these Partners
we also want to give a shout out to all
of our broadcasting partners for
supporting today's showcase and the
developers on the stream thank you so
much to Twitch IGN Gamespot and steam
and as a final reminder games from today
will also be a part of our mix next
steam page so make sure you check that
out and wishlist the games we want to
also give a shout out to the mix team
for putting this all together Timmy Mary
Joel Travis Matt Abe James Victoria
Wilmer sound fully Illustrated and of
course candy thank you Justin for sure
make sure to follow us on Twitter at
Indie exchange and everywhere else at
media Indie exchange up next we are
hopping into the black voice and gaming
showcase which is a non-profit
organization that brings visibility
acceleration and access to opportunities
to Black game developers while giving
them a voice we are now passing the mic
to Destiny and red infamy again I am
Justin Woodward and I'm Candace McKinney
take it away guys and we'll see you real
soon
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
coming hot off the mix thank you so much
for that intro candy and Jay hello
everyone it's so good to be back I love
hosting black voices in gaming and I'm
always honored to be here it's
incredible to see where bvig started and
how its growth is positively affecting
the game community and the industry my
name is Destiny and you may know me as
one of the hosts from burnout writer as
well as bonus level over at level one
gaming but before I go any further I'm
gonna pass the mic over to my homie my
amazing co-host and let her introduce
herself
thanks so much Destiny I'm excited uh so
happy to be back as well and to host
with you to host with you uh my name is
red infamy you're a massive geektris a
veteran journalist that has covered
things from gaming Esports geek culture
I'm also the founder and creator of geek
game type media and also a really cool
uh web series hidden code which actually
shed light on black Hispanic and native
game developers from all around the
world uh plus hosts on afropunks culture
code so I'm really excited today because
it is going to be an honor to talk to
these incredible developers that is a
part of black voices and Gaming
Community that we're going to see
actually from all around the world so
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
today to learn more about these
incredible developers and another note
is follow us so you can keep up to date
with what we're doing and we have our
Twitter page which is B VI a gaming also
check out our YouTube and Instagram
which is black voices and gaming so
Destiny let us know more about black
voices and gaming
it is my pleasure black voices and
gaming was created in June of 2020
during the protests and demonstrations
that United us worldwide it's a
non-profit organization that helps
accelerate the growth of professional
game developers our mission is to
facilitate a pace where game Studio
entrepreneurs can access funding
Publishers press and mentors to help
them succeed
now I know we have some sponsors that we
want to thank red go ahead and throw
that in there
and definitely because without them we
wouldn't have this so give a huge shout
out to our partners for today's showcase
which includes raw fairy they actually
help us get this uh actually started and
assisted with funding throughout the
series uh for the year PlayStation Intel
Game Dev boost boost ID at Xbox razor
and Kickstarter
plus let's also give a shout out to our
broadcasting Partners which is Twitch
gaming steam IGN and Game Spot
so last but not least we also have a
steam event page this is where you'll
get to learn more about the developers
after the show and during the show check
out their games there's some demos there
buy them and also you can wish list as
well so you can get updates on the the
games in case they're not out yet and
also make sure y'all want to donate to
our black voices and gaming on tiltify
so you can search us if you want to
support further uh you can do so on
there
so let's jump into our first guess our
first developer Sucker For Love by
Joseph AKA akabaka stay tuned for the
driller
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
memories
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
oh my God I love that trailer I
literally feel like I'm about to sit
down and binge an entire anime red what
did you entire anime I thought it was
incredible like the theme song alone
just sent me there like nostalgic wise
so I can't wait for us to chat with the
Creator Joseph AKA AKA Baka you sucker
for love what are you doing
hey guys uh so yeah like they said I'm
makabaka I'm Joseph Hunter I'm the lead
developer for sucker for love and
chromatos
let's do the programming at Art and I've
been a game developer for about four or
five years now
oh my gosh when you say you do the art
and the programming and you've only been
doing it for about four or five years
I'm just blown away because your game
looks I know this sounds weird when
people say I look so professional but
like literally for somebody who just
started not too long ago it looks like
something that would come out of like a
triple a studio for a dating simulator
and I absolutely love it one of my
questions was what made you decide to do
a dating simulator as your as this game
right so that's a really good question
and that's for the uh for um sucker for
love was originally just a submission to
uh dread xp's dredx collection which is
like a game Jam only they um chose who
entered and we were paid up front for it
and the theme for that game Jam was love
crafting so it had to have love
mechanics crafting mechanics and the
crafting hard
um I didn't have a whole lot of crafting
experience like I could have spent the
entire 10-day runtime just making the
logic for a crafting system and so I
decided Well
making items and then using them is kind
of like crafting so what kinds of games
have both items that you create and use
and love mechanics and dating Sims do
and so the only missing piece of the
puzzle at that point was uh lovecraftian
horror and so to put it all together
it's a dating stuff out look crafty and
Horrors
well the game is incredible it's doing
insanely well if you guys don't know
it's already up on Steam so go get it
you just uh released a new DLC and we're
going to take a look at some of the
gameplay red is going to handle that
like she's the pro at this so red let's
get started and if we have any questions
we have Joseph here to help us out as we
go through it yes so Joseph can you tell
us a little bit about the design the art
style because I know it's very
influenced by anime but tell us like why
you picked the characters you picked how
like
I guess what I'm saying is like what
really influenced you and the way that
you picked your characters like lynetta
and then like some of the other ones
so ultimately sucker for love was a love
letter to
um three things it was lovecrafty and
hard dating Sims and Anime and so all of
the uh characters and design choices
that show up usually are some sort of
callback to one of those three like um
the art style itself is very similar to
Odessa yatsura and Golden Boy to
um like 90s anime and then the main
character himself personality it was
very similar to kintaro from Golden Boy
so um when it comes to
um design choices usually something here
is kind of directly influenced by
um something that I really loved
watching in the 90s or so
that's incredible it's nice to see that
you can take things that you really like
felt inspired you and you've put them
all into this game and they they just
work seamlessly like I've never seen a
dating game like this before and some of
the things that I really noticed was how
you have to set up the room and set up
places in order to conduct some of these
spells so red is going through that
right now she just pulled up the book
can you talk a little bit about the
gaming mechanics and how you go about
like furthering your gameplay
yeah so um you touched on it but um all
of the um design choices
um including the mechanics in the book
are all kind of here
so that anime
lovecraftian horror and dating Sims
which is three genres kind of known for
being kind of difficult to get into
being a little bit obtuse
um trying to make this as fun and
accessible around through all three of
those at once
and so this um this uh ritual system
ideally is in the words of Toby Fox
designed to be a game that your older
sister could play
like it's it's um yeah it's it's it's
and that's kind of
um the angle I took with every element
being the depths of lovecraftian horror
where the anime references is that your
older sister would essentially be able
to walk away and be like oh I understand
what Cthulhu is and and and sort of the
basics of cosmic card now so
um basically accessibility was the big
uh
um Target and fun fact that did work
especially for the original demo uh we
had like the achievement statistics on
each of the games and 80 of people that
bought the jedx collection to
um completed sucker for love compared to
the 40 average
oh wow that's incredible and I think
accessibility is really really important
when you're playing a game
um what I just wanted to point out one
of the things I absolutely love like one
of the mechanics I love is when you use
the mouth to read out the Spells I just
thought that was like incredible because
I don't know why but every time you get
to that part I'm like What's It Gonna
sound like this time so
um one of my questions which I know is
probably weird but like it's in a
different kind of language how did you
come about with doing that like
you could have just done it without it
saying anything but like what made you
decide to actually get those words out
there because I really feel like I'm
like casting a spell when I'm playing
this game
so I actually referenced known really
and I um oh okay
reverse engineer lots of stuff like if
you remember the king and yellow play
from the second chapter
um that's not an actual play that really
exists I I went back and looked up
everything that's known about the play
and then kind of built it on my own
using like turkey whatever things that
make it sound like real art likewise
with the Spells and everything or when
she's teaching you're really in I looked
up
um known phrases and really and what
they mean and then kind of figured out
in Reverse okay so then this means that
that means that and if I want to say
this and I use this word this word and
that word and it makes it feel a little
authentic when you're doing the Spells
and you're reading
I literally thought the play was a real
play like you did so that's incredible
okay so jumping from that let's talk a
little bit about the voicing because all
of the main characters have voice
actresses and they're incredible they
absolutely slay it please and like kudos
to them from us tell us about that how
did you go about picking them and
finding the right tone to fit those
personalities
right so I already knew the voice
actress for lynetta who's Michaela laws
because she'd been playing my other game
chromatos on stream for a while
um it's like the only reason that I
started getting like attention on
chromatos because she was like kind of a
big streamer and this is my first game
um so we've been kind of we kind of go
back a ways and so while I was working
on this game for the um gym uh she had
volunteered to lend her voice to it
since it was kind of a small quick and
dirty project and when the reception was
really good we brought her back for the
whole for the whole game and she you
know knocked the whole game out of the
park too then for um Esther
um I had played this other game River
City girls by Way Forward games and oh I
love that was playing it I kept getting
distracted because all the voices were
so good and I was like I kept pausing so
I could jot down okay this character's
voice is really good for this and um
when I was coming around for casting for
Sucker For Love
um the first date I just kind of went
through that short list of people and
landed on Kaylee Mills checked out the
other stuff that she had done brought
her for an audition and she landed the
role without me ever auditioning anybody
else
because it was just a really good
audition I think she was gonna kill it
yeah and then the last one I had
yeah I mean for the last one I had two
people in mind but
um either of them were available or
didn't get back to me and so the thing
that they had in common that I was
really looking for was that they were
women over 40 or 50. and so I just kind
of put on my Twitter hello is there any
va's kind of in my mutuals that is over
40 or 50 years old because I really
wanted for uh Auntie nyanyan to feel
like it's really a bigger you know
someone senior or Superior to you
talking down to you and the best way to
get that feeling is to have someone that
is actually older than you deliver these
lines and wow
Manila was like how can I help you and
then her post got like 20s 30 60 likes I
was like who is this and then I look up
her roles and she's like Rouge the Bat
Ivy Valentine she's in blizzard games
she's in all sorts of games like oh
she's everybody ever and she also did
the audition and killed it and I didn't
bother auditioning anybody else and then
she went ahead to deliver probably the
most popular performance in soccer for
love so far everyone's kind of gaga gaga
I love her like she's like she takes
names and like puts you in your place
like immediately and it's incredible the
attention to detail that you've put into
this game really shows how much of a
passion project this is for you
um can you tell us a little bit about
future projects or possibly like things
that you might add on because I feel
like this is a game that could go on and
on like I said I could binge it like an
anime so please tell me there's more
there is more and it's coming up uh
maybe this winter it's gonna be sucker
for love the second one which is date
two Die four and it's um this one's
about the black goat of the Woods
and it features a new protagonist a new
love interest new threats and this one
is actually going to be kind of
interesting because
um normally when you see a lovecraftian
horror game it's all about Cthulhu this
outer gods that so on and so forth when
you actually look at lovecraft's work
you see a good chunk of them are
actually just about people or
demi-humans like Shadow over innsmith or
Dunwich Horror and so for the second
game uh the threats are mainly going to
be enemy cultists and other human beings
have been met by uh the effects of these
other gods as opposed to the other gods
themselves in a way to in an attempt to
kind of do lovecraft's writings Justice
that's incredible I really want to learn
more about it just because I I've heard
about it but I this game really made me
want to like get into it and like learn
like what you picked from it and how it
like influenced your game so like I can
tell through the art style but like I
really want to get into the lore so I'm
really excited to see the next game that
you drop or the next DLC that you
dropped for it I'm gonna throw it to red
red do you have any questions because
you've been doing a great job playing
the game and I know I've been taking so
much time
um so that's okay that's all right
um yeah so so basically like just me
experience this is my first like dating
game period like so I just love how of
course the art style is giving me
Inuyasha Sailor Moon ish like I love
that nostalgic 90s Vibe early 90s but
like he's not scared at all like the
characters not scared at all that this
Cthulhu first of all she had looked like
a straight up demon out of nowhere just
come up he's okay with summoning things
and he wants to kiss this scary thing
that's in his room was there any like
what themes involve of course a theme is
is Lovecraft but what's something that
you wanted to kind of bind in together
because it is a cute lovable looking
game but there's some Sinister like
Darkness to it as well
yeah so there's a lot there
um one thing that was kind of really
nice about the Jedi's collections was
that while it was only 10 days long it
was our benefit that it was only 10 days
long so we could do something kind of
zany like I could make a game where oh I
don't know you have a girl with a squid
on her face and you have to kiss her or
something crazy like that and
um
um that came from
Personal Taste where kind of monster
girls are getting really popular these
days but a lot of times they kind of
wimp out on making the monsters if they
say oh yeah this is the Neko model like
a cat Monster Roll it'll take like a
regular anime girl
um and then put cat ears on her and call
it a day or actually with Lovecraft
specifically they have hayory nyakochan
which is a it's literally an anime about
a bunch of girls that are lovecrafty and
like Gods and Monsters but if you looked
at their designs you'd never be able to
guess which one was which at all because
they don't resemble monsters they just
look like regular girls and so one thing
I really wanted to do especially since
there was like minimal risk with this
game was make a a monster that looks
like a monster girl and ideally when I
had all of the um characters laid out
side by side they would someone who
would know nothing about Lovecraft would
be able to match each character with a
picture of the monster they're based on
kind of easily and then the other design
choice that you had touched on red was
um the main character is not like
terrified of of lynetta he just wants to
kiss so that while also like funny was
deliberate because it's a it's a um
Mainstay of lovecraftian horror for the
main character to be obsessed with
something to the point of insanity so in
his case he's obsessed with getting a
smooch no matter how scary the situation
or what's at stake and so while really
funny it's also lore accurate that ain't
got it that's that's great
like the way you were able to make the
monsters look lovable and cute and still
keep like that whole vibe going was
really really good because I don't know
how I would have made a squid face look
adorable and lynetta is super adorable
like I have no problem with him kissing
her because I'm like that makes sense
she's she's attractive you know that was
actually really hard when I was in the
original designs
um because I I thought the angle to go
about it was to make them like really
sexy at first but when you take
something creepy and try to make it sexy
you just make something creepier
unfortunately and so I I I I had to like
the nurses in Silent Hill
um I mean
[Laughter]
but um Silent Hill is a good example
it'd be really easy to take like pyramid
head and then make him like chibi and
cutesy and like I don't know I'm holding
a pumpkin and now it's like super cute
like really easily and so uh I started
trying to twist things to a really you
know like pinkish very cute very
adorable big eye sort of cutesy anime
it's in order to make Elevate silver
Char is attractive yeah you did a great
job it looks amazing so the last
question I wanted to ask you to just
touch on really quickly is I know you
have a lot of like Japanese influence
um anime influence and they're really
not known to put a lot of minorities in
their um games or movies do you plan on
putting more minorities in future games
the next protagonist of Sucker For Love
is a black female
so yeah
he loves it oh
we are running out of time so before we
end this Joseph if people want to find
you find out more about you find out
more about the games that you're going
to be producing can you go ahead and
plug your socials for us
right so
um Sucker For Love first aid is out on
Steam
um if you wanted to try it before buying
it there is a sucker full of Prelude
also on Steam which is a free demo
um for updates on what's coming down the
pipe for uh soccer for 11 chromatos I
have my Twitter which is at chromatostef
and on my Twitter I've linked my Discord
where there's content fan art all sorts
of stuff so if you want to sort of keep
up with what's coming uh either check
out my Discord or check out my Twitter
awesome well thank you so much for
coming on spending some time with us and
showing us yes thank you sucker love
yeah that was amazing Joseph
you're incredible cannot wait thank you
so much
yeah now thank you guys uh thanks for
the interview
you're welcome
all right that was amazing I hope you
guys go and play that game go wish
listed even if you can't buy it it
really helps with the algorithm it shows
steam that you guys like the game but we
have some more guests coming up because
this is just the beginning of the show
so we are going to watch the next
trailer for bats bloodsucker anti-terror
Squad by Daryl Reed get ready to check
it out
foreign
[Music]
ruthless enemies
[Music]
that's not supposed to happen dogs
execute the game developers immediately
where was I oh yes I commend you to buy
bats the game or I will have your feet
removed and make you up unstuck and
everyone will laugh at you
scorpion Supreme signing off
someone bringing us up
[Music]
oh my god listen I wish I had a bowl of
cereal right now because I feel like
that I'm sitting cartoon television and
it's cartoon time like definitely
Saturday morning cartoon Vibes cartoons
incredible love the whole meta thing
where he's like buy the game now and if
you don't I'm gonna cut off your feet
yeah he broke he broke the fourth floor
too saying execute the game developers
that's great which is a great segue
because we have the game developer on in
just a few seconds I'm going to be
introducing Daryl Reed Daryl thank you
so much for coming on and being with us
I'm glad you're here thank you because I
was afraid you might not
you wanted to execute yourself
so Daryl can you tell us a little bit
about yourself what got you into the
gaming realm what inspired you to make
bats specifically because it's
incredible I love it
wow but specifically this was actually a
game
um For Hire so it was made the idea was
um came up by a group called one-eyed
robot they had the idea of making a
television show which was um based on
the 80s cartoon and they wanted to
produce a game to go with the shot go
with the television show and the premise
behind the game was um to make it look
like a Nintendo or a Super Nintendo
Super Nintendo here again so sort of
like
yeah to sort of match up with the 80s
theme it is nice theme of the um cartoon
so that's where the idea for this
particular game came from
um
about myself and I'll go into game
development is through flash games
um yeah making Flash games for a number
of years as well as uh some HTML5 games
some mobile apps and then um
transitioned into making console games
now
so have you always been a gamer yourself
this is something that you have you
always wanted to develop games
yeah yeah I suppose I also grew up in a
generation where you know everyone had a
Sagamore system or Nintendo then they
are Super Nintendo Mega Drive
PlayStation so I was always sort of like
had a so interesting um you know I wish
I could develop my own game sort of
thing and then um later on start just
sort of accidentally stumbled across
Flash
and um from there base took it from
there basically because it was obviously
a platform where you could easily sort
of teach yourself how to program
um I had an art background already so I
could create my assets at that time
myself so um it was sort of like it was
Flash was very Royal geared to like a
single person developer just creating
your own games and then obviously there
was a whole industry built around it
where you could sell licenses to these
games and actually like I made quite
like a decent amount of money to be fair
like um
so yeah but then obviously that sort of
faded off and as that faded off I
transitioned into um
console games making games for PC and
console I think that's incredible
because like when you said it's like
sort of easy you just teach yourself out
of program I can't do it so kudos to you
for being able to pull that off because
I don't think I could develop a game by
myself but let's go ahead and pull up
this game because it's absolutely
incredible like you said they wanted to
give it that 90s 80s theme and I swear
to God I I definitely owned that TV
that's in the trailer like I definitely
have that TV and I definitely watch
cartoons on it and played my Super
Nintendo on it and all of that stuff so
you you nailed it like bats is
definitely one of those games I feel
like I could have like couch co-opt with
my little brother and it's incredible
one of the questions I wanted to ask is
I know you're working with the team to
produce these games called ritual games
what's it like working with that team
and working on all these different
titles
opponent will Retro Game 3 sticks myself
and one other guy he usually handles the
art exclusively now or as I handle
exclusively the programming and in terms
of the game design and everything else
we work together as a team sort of hash
things out and um yeah we've been
working together for
years now so we're sort of it's
like a good team I think like yeah yeah
yeah we used to
um each other's flow and how how we work
what so yeah nice it's
it's good
and you guys are based out of the UK
right
at the moment I'm in Spain but
originally yeah we were um we're based
in well he's based in London we're
originally based in London so yeah from
the UK
so being here in the U.S and like I I
realized that like I've been talking
with other content creators and things
like that how is it working in the UK
how is it working as like a black game
developer in the UK are they more open
because here I feel like it takes a lot
more work to be seen how is it there
like do you feel like you get the
support you need
well to be honest the whole time sort of
I've Been Working creating games is is
sort of been in isolation in terms of
you know as a solo developer or working
in a small teams of one or two people
especially in the flash industry it was
like you'd create the game and then
you'd sell the license and a lot of the
people you you're dealing with you don't
meet them like it's just it's all sort
of you're dealt with online so in terms
of the question of sort of like race or
ethnicity doesn't sort of really come
into it in that sense because like
nobody knows who you are right like like
or where you're from it's just you sort
of like
it is I've sort of been I suppose in in
some sense you sort of say it's isolated
in the UK or um at least the way we was
working so we weren't sort of really
until recently sort of um
in
like uh sort of like meeting up with
people in the game development scene or
sort of had the opportunity to sort of
like um network is what I'm looking to
see yeah so sort of like we were sort of
like more a lot more isolated than just
a two one or two man teams working
together and and that's it and then like
when we did deal with people it was
mainly it's like exclusively online
got it so how does it feel being a part
of the black voices and game Community
because coming from someone who usually
worked by themselves or just worked with
another team member now you're like
you're on the Showcase you're you're
talking to other people people are
seeing your game how does it feel to be
a part of this
to be honest yeah no it's it's been
great especially like shout out to
Justin it's like um
isn't it a great help to get the insight
and ideas of um
other people is with experience other
experienced game developers and just on
other people's ideas in general sort of
like also as well um
opening up sort of access
to um
like funding and other opportunities
that you sort of that you definitely
wouldn't get if you just sort of like
isolated and buy yourself creating games
so he has been like a great experience
I love that you bring that up because
that is something that's so important
and what they're trying to do as a
non-profit is give game developers a way
to succeed and and create these games
and give them opportunities that
otherwise they probably wouldn't have
had so I love that you brought that up
but now that we have the game running
which is incredible I love like a good
like I'm not saying this is a button
Smasher but that's probably how I would
play it it's just going through and like
totally annihilating everything tell me
a little bit more about the mechanics as
you're playing the game well as red is
playing the game because she's the pro
here so
well we wanted to sort of design it
obviously it was a throwback to um old
school Nintendo and Super Nintendo Super
Nintendo games so on one hand obviously
you wanted to keep everything sort of
basic we didn't want things to be too
too many buttons and and too many
different mechanics but like at the same
time we wanted to keep things fast paced
So like um
yeah and you see it's like a relatively
fast-paced game like that sort of pushes
the player to keep going forward and
keep moving
um we wanted to add like a comedy
element to it as well to sort of like
that's that's the whole vibe of the AE
show that it's supposed to be based on
sort of like
crazy cartoonish landish enemies doing
um you know like you can see they'll run
into their own traps and get cured by
their own traps and stuff like that
um a lot of slapsticks yeah I love it
yes yes slapstick humor like um we had a
lot of inspiration from like Capcom
arcade games so like there's one
or the um elevator action I think it was
called where there was a lot of
verticality so we wanted to sort of like
really incorporate that
um
Hotline Miami and Katana zero as well
were The Inspirations for this game were
obviously going to keep things like I
was saying fast-paced one hit kills lots
of blood
and yeah I love it it reminds me of like
metal slug too like but when I beat him
up situation is one of my favorites
yeah this is the type of game that I
would play and not worried about like
um having to memorize like uh you know
when you're playing a lot of fighting
games and you have to memorize certain
things because
yeah if I find one move that can kick
your butt I will constantly use oh
you're in a cheeser okay
because I don't have any more room in my
brain to be remembering a bunch of
differently
like combinations but this looks so fun
and I love it you know it also gives me
and you didn't mention this game but it
also gives me a very Mega Man feel when
I look at the game and the gameplay like
I definitely see Mega Man and especially
this guy that he's fighting at the end
like you guys did such a good job and
especially being a two-man team this
looks really really good oh I gotta get
up
by like Mega Man and Sonic the Hedgehog
style enemies yeah I see
oh my God
people
want to find out more about the game
where can they find you
on Twitter uh underscore ritual
underscore games
awesome and do you have a Discord or
anything like that where people can talk
to you or just Twitter
um I've got a Discord
um
no no
I've got my personality yeah you're like
I don't know if I want to do I would not
do that absolutely not
but I I wish I would love
and I was gonna say I will love like a
multiplayer aspect because the bats crew
is interesting like brother over here
look like blade was it like uh
inspiration from like vampire movies as
well that y'all wanted to integrate in
there
yeah so I feel like with all the the
whole idea is like they're uh
anti-terror Squad made terrorist Squad
made of vampires right so you've got
their main guys supposed to be based on
Karen Dracula then you've got like
blades like Nosferatu and um yeah then
you've got the two other characters I'm
not entirely sure who they are based on
but that the whole the whole idea is the
group are a bunch of vampires
18 for them
I love it I'm trying to beat him up I'm
trying to do it you can do it he's
you're so close
is any like
crazy boss fights in here
oh I did it oh my God
you can tell many games really good and
everybody gets quiet and they they get
closer to the screen even if they're not
playing it you know what I mean
but Daryl this was incredible thank you
so much for coming on spending some time
with us and showing oh my God there's
blade
I had to I had to lock him no I'm so
glad you did I mean this is black voices
and gaming so let's get some color in
there so I love getting the unlock blade
but thank you so much y'all for coming
on and talking to us and showing us your
game it's incredible I'm still blown
away that it's a two-person team who's
created this and can you tell us do you
have anything else in the works
yeah at a moment we're working on um an
unannounced title I'll see you okay all
right cool well you ain't got time you
almost got you you almost got you yeah
we almost we almost he almost dropped
some information for us but everybody
thank you so much Gerald thank you so
much for coming on remember go follow
him on Twitter go get the game on Steam
if you can't afford it like it wish
listed it always helps developers steam
is always looking at that algorithm red
was there anything else you wanted to
say before we move on
oh thank you so much for creating an
awesome game I will be streaming this
especially since it is like a spook
Timber Thing theme going on so I
definitely am going to stream this I
love it and can't wait to see your
future projects
thanks Daryl I'm not speaking with you
guys see you later
all right guys that was bats and that
was incredible like it was so much fun
right you handled it you got a place you
gotta play I'm gonna play it I'm gonna
play it I'm gonna play when you stream
it I even have like a speed run I'm
gonna do a speed run when I beat the
game I'm I'm gonna try and I never did a
speed run in my life but I think this
this game would be it
what content
but we're not done yet did you guys
think we were done we're not because we
have a ton more to show and I'm gonna
throw it to Red because I think she's
really excited about our next guest
who's coming up
oh and deed indeed so if you're a
samurai person like I am love history
and you know about one of the first
black samurais that you are gonna be in
for a treat as we have yasuke a lost
descended by thee will go Sarah so stay
tuned and let's check it out
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I've been waiting
for the very moment
wake me again
once I was lost
[Music]
oh yes
oh my God
okay sorry Ricky killed it and he killed
it like this is the most incredibly oh
my God okay I'm sorry I'm just so hot
can we run it again no I'm sorry let's
just let's just jump right now
yes uh yo we have the incredible will
guasara of Dolly it's about saying
Dalian Studios right here with us thank
you let us know more about you and your
humble beginnings and game development
well okay so hi I'm Olga Sarah
um and I guess how I started all of this
was um it's funny because I wasn't
actually supposed to like like my
original goal wasn't to be in game
development
um it was to be an actor funnily enough
uh and then it was one day I came across
the game Dragon Ball Xenoverse
um and I started modding the game I was
like oh what if I added this character
in that what if I added this character
and years went by with like um I think
it was five years total I spent modding
that game because there was uh as
Universe one and then two
um I met some really cool people along
the way and it was around 2019 I was
with one of my friends who I met during
that journey and all that and we were
speaking to each other and we were like
what if we made a game like what if we
just stopped modding and made our own
game so the first uh game that we
technically started creating was a JoJo
fan game
um it was made with like
yeah I literally got a poster over that
um
so yeah we started off making like it
was like a pixel game
um and I'm gonna say this right now even
though the visuals would change I'm
still planning to remake that game in
the future anyways uh
so yeah it was gonna be a really good
game but it's like mad expensive
especially for a starter game for like
two people so we're like okay let's
leave that awful we'll move off it um
and then that's when you know that
friend of mine went up to do his own
things so I but I was like let me I want
to continue on this whole journey so
next started up was a Demon Slayer fan
game uh this was demos like he was just
curves and this is when I guess uh the
traction started showing up of like
people seeing you know I'm trying to
start up this game Studio stuff and
doing all that
um so again I had gotten the help from a
couple friends I had met during this
universe days
um and then loads of other people I've
met along the way like from Twitter and
station and we started making this game
you know started making the character
models animations and then it got to the
point so development was pretty slow I
will say that much because especially
since none of us were being paid it was
more like a fan project people I think
they need to do that sort of thing and
then it was one fateful day when cyber
connect 2 dropped the trailer that they
were making a demon sway game and that
was right
now
here's the thing as well right because
this was when like I was also really
starting to get serious like I that's
when I registered the company
um I was speaking to like the uh license
holders asking like you know who are the
people that hold licenses anyone making
the games so uh the ones I'd asked was
aniplex of course because they do the
anime and then Bandai Namco
um and I'm specifically remember be
getting the email back from Bandai
saying no we don't hold the rights we
don't do any of that so I'm thinking
okay there's no demon say again we're
chilling we're gonna be we're gonna be
on the board and then yeah it suddenly
gets drunk
I think you were the one that actually
made that project happen because
they're like there's a market so now we
know who was behind the creation of
I love it so I have some questions for
you you are pretty much the youngest
game developer I've ever had a chance to
talk to and interview as well and I
believe in Black voices and gaming
history so how has that been as being
one of the youngest you seem very
confident and passionate you have a
passion for anime how has that been uh
being a young developer and leading your
own team as a young entrepreneur too and
being so young
it's a it's a 50 50. you know because
like it's amazing being able to start up
like creating this story and stuff like
that and then especially with the team
having these people believe in what this
story is going to be and helping you
along with creating it like let's take
with yasuke and everything that we've
made for it so far none of us are being
paid yet we haven't gotten any sort of
investment or nothing like that so what
this is all like purely on the belief
that everyone believes this will be a
big uh project so that's how we're
continuing and why we're continuing
um and then the other side of it is like
it is stressful I will say that right
now it is stressful
um because even like let's say the days
where you know being the director of
what you want to be on break you
technically can never be on break
because other people will still be
working you still need to you know tell
them how things need to be done deal
with this is that
um and then yeah I don't know it's just
it's a it's a 50 50 side of things and I
feel like especially with the um age
side of it like I've had those before
where it's like oh I wish I could be the
sort of people that's like you know
going out doing parties all the time
that sort of thing but I'm kind of more
indoors doing this sort of game
development and it's great it was like
great as it would be to do that party
stuff it's on the same case that I know
this is going to really help me for the
future and like set it all out and
having that thought in mind all the time
exactly it's always time and when you
have like some like developer game money
you could really party party you know
what I'm saying yeah
for sure so
the mute like okay we was hyped off of
the trailer alone the visuals were crazy
I am one for of course learning more
about art history and our like history
as an African diaspora all around the
world like we're in every spot of the
world as black people uh yasuke you know
learning about yasuke and you are of
course in touch with anime so of course
Japanese culture how did you pick up
learning about yasuke and flipping it to
yasuke's against obanu uh Nobunaga like
how did you did you want to do that flip
because we've seen other iterations and
of course there was an anime on yasuke
but you actually flipped it that okay
he's your rival instead of actually
being instead of yasuke being the actual
right hand man to Nobunaga which
historical historically that's how it
was so can you talk us through that
so essentially how it all fast started
was uh when mapper dropped the yasuke
anime on Netflix and that is when I
first learned about the character or
like the real historical figure and then
I started doing my research reading more
into it so I was like I really like this
um that was also roughly the same time I
was dropping the demon State game
because then we're moving strong to this
um so first the game was actually going
to be a game straight up about that
historical figure like old times all
that sort of stuff and we had developed
it for like a month or two this was when
I say like we this was very early like
it was just me and my friend who did uh
the character concept designs and stuff
um so yeah we were designing it and
doing all that's preparing it and then
one day I was like you know as cool as
this is I'm all for like future neon
that sort of stuff so what if we took it
to the Future what if we just like
changed it and that's when the term a
lost descendant comes in because this is
supposed to be the descendant of that so
and obviously I can't spoil things that
go on within the story that's planned
but there will be all sorts of things
that derive why they're Rivals you
probably saw the silhouette in the
trailer of them knowing each other when
they were kids all that sort of stuff
it's it's a very in-depth story as to
why they're against each other and I
feel like at the same time
um
it's like there's no right side
technically to say because that's one
thing I do love is when stories let you
interpret who like who you believe in
and stuff so in with our story I can
very much believe that some people will
be on the side of Oda compared to the
side of yasuke it all depends on
people's perspectives and Views but
we'll see how that turns out of course
all day right
so that's my man
all right you already have now you have
to make merchandise because she already
has the husbando yeah
a whole pillow you have to make a whole
pillow for her we got we got much
planned I'll tell you that much we do oh
okay dope exclusive all right so we got
first play I love how afrobeats is like
merged with it the whole hip-hop and I
love also the message in one of the
songs too like the Hallelujah and
um another song as well so let us know
pretty much I know your brother he's a
musical artist himself and one of the
cool things that I got to learn
um more about your family which was cool
because I have that same camaraderie
with my little brother like my little
brother is so smart but he I inspired
him too but I always look forward to his
knowledge and what he has to say about
my own work and I love how y'all have
that together he said like you're the
one he goes to First how was it being so
young to actually have that at home and
then when you have to go work around
people that's older than you do you
think you get that same respect or are
you prepared for it
um well yeah I guess like having worked
with because I've always worked with
older people or like been around older
people like even going back to when I
was
um younger like in my early teens like
12 stuff like that
um
just off to school clubs and things I
would always usually be with the older
kids compared to the younger ones so
that sort of stuff is why you know
that's derived but in terms of like how
it's all gone down with my brother and
all that
um essentially like yeah we we kind of
have this inside thing that I'm his
advisor when it comes to music and all
that sort of stuff like I am the first
person he comes to you know he'll take
my opinion and what uh what I think of
it if something needs to be changed that
sort of thing and um so funnily enough
he didn't like he did afrobeats every
now and again but he didn't prioritize
it at first right uh and then I remember
it was like maybe sometime last year the
year before he was saying to me like oh
I feel like afrobeats is what people
really enjoy out of my music and I was
like yeah you should go and do it more
that sort of stuff and then obviously
came the creation of yasuke and we were
like what if we put that on the game and
see how it goes that's fine I've never
seen a game where where afrobeats is set
for like a sports game about like I'm
talking about real game like this you
know whether it's sci-fi fantasy
especially seeing us as black people and
these different type of genres of things
that's fiction wise to have afrobeats in
it like I was
doing my little dance so
um so your brother is a part of this of
the soundtrack
yeah so we have
um a music producer who makes the Beats
um and then my brother does the vocal
stuff and obviously he mixes it all
together that sort of thing
um and yeah that's how it goes around
it's like it's funny how life works in
the case that so the song that played in
the intro Alleluia
um that wasn't originally a song made
for yasuke that was just a song that he
said like you know it came to him one
day he wants to make it that sort of
thing and when I went to his house and
he was like oh I got a new song to show
you let me play this and then we're
listening to the lyrics and we're like
how does this actually fit in with
yasuke because he's starting to talk
about how you know he's from the bottom
he's coming up to the top uh even some
of the lyrics like yeah is the best like
things like that it has that double
meaning so
um yeah that's how we then just started
creating more stuff and putting on more
for the soundtrack and even with
afrobeats what our plan is because our
cost is actually like mad diverse
um for example Mia the character who's
speaking in the background she is um
Latin American
um
and music wise we add like tingents and
little pieces from different cultures
into the afrobeats so her theme would
have things that correlate to that and
so on and so forth so yeah uh things
like that Otis theme has Japanese
instruments playing in the background
but it still mixes in with the afrobeats
and we have loads more people I'm
talking we have people like from Egypt
we have Europeans it goes in it goes in
I love that attitude I love it it's an
absolutely incredible
um and I know you touched a bit about
being an actor earlier but like you're
actually voicing the main character so
was that always something you wanted to
do you're like I'm gonna put myself in
my game or was that something that like
it came to me
it just kind of like happened one day
because it was most specifically so on
uh YouTube channels we have the first
devra pool and the first announcement
trailer
um so during the dev report that was
um transitioning to the new yasuke model
so the whole time I was creating that
new yasuke model I was like adding bits
of myself into his character design
things like the gold rings in his hair
that is because whenever I have my
twists I usually have gold rings in my
hair the eyebrow slit all that sort of
stuff so I was like What if I just like
voice him as well because it may as well
yeah because even speaking it's just
like an 18 year old black male obviously
I'm 19 now but that sort of thing so I
just thought yeah may as well and okay
what I mean like you wanted to act voice
acting is like the next best thing and
it's your own creation so why not put
yourself in it
um one of the questions I wanted to ask
you before we like wrap everything up
because this has been amazing and I
cannot wait to actually play this game
but how do you feel about being here on
black voices and gaming like actually
contributing to our culture because like
that's something that's so important and
something that me and red really really
love being a part of is being here and
being introduced to you and other
developers how do you feel that black
voices is helping you reach your goals
with your game
oh it's amazing it's actually such a
good opportunity like
um it's funny how it happened in the
case that uh Justin messaging out to me
just being like uh because we were
showing him gameplay Clips obviously for
the side stuff but then he was like oh
what if you joined the part of our stuff
and what if like you joined the makes
and black voices in gaming and that's
where you drop your trailer and honestly
I'm so glad that he did because being on
this like this opportunity this is the
reason we were able to push ourselves so
far and even with that trailer we showed
we're still not happy with it because we
didn't have enough time to flesh out as
much as we wanted to there were so many
scenes we had to cut or we can polish as
much as we wanted to
um and it's I don't know what else you
wanted to add yeah
save it for the game save it for the
game and for the game yeah yeah that's
what like people I guess they'll see the
little hints of what we can do but when
I tell you like when we have as much
time as we need and having the resources
we have we are going to blow people's
minds away because the things we have
planned and the visuals we want to pull
off because our team is like a lot of
artists so obviously we want to pull up
that visual look uh more specifically
you know we have a lot of our references
are things like Arcane into the spite of
us things like that
um
because I could definitely see that Vibe
being in your game but all right yeah
look
I wanted to interrupt you a million
times and and pull a Kanye
all time but listen that that literally
I just seeing that trailer I am so hyped
like I don't think I've seen a trailer
that's gotten me that excited and that I
felt like yo this is for us buy us for
us this is incredible yes you've done
such an amazing job if it's amazing
wanted to find out more about this game
more about you and your goals and what
you're going to be doing in the future
where can they find you
oh well as it was on the end of the
trailer you have a social media uh
Studio dalliance or my own uh Twitter
which is dalliance r g we have our
YouTube channel down in studios and then
there's also the Discord server which is
where you'll like talk to us a bit more
close
um we're usually they're posting updates
and just chilling around we used to do
like game nights and all that sort of
stuff but then obviously during the time
we started to crack down on development
we couldn't do it as much but we're
gonna start bringing it back Community
things all that sort of stuff so yeah
that's pretty much where you can find us
awesome I'm super excited do you
basically like give me just a little
sneak peek like when when do you think
you might have like a demo for for uh
for people to like play
that is a very good I know that's a hard
question
we're out of here I just want something
to look forward to okay
uh let's say for a demo either
sometime at the end of this year or
beginning of next year so around 30
years
exclusive
exclusive content thank you so much for
coming on I cannot wait to check out the
demo guys make sure that you check out
this game make sure you go follow them
give them all the support you need well
not you need all the support that they
need and um yeah that was oh my God that
was so good that was so good but we're
not done and um
we have some amazing things coming up
next that I'm excited about it's time to
give a special shout out to some of the
developers who are part of black voices
in gaming and the community so we're
going to show a couple of trailers that
you guys may have seen or may not have
seen you may see him for the first time
but they're absolutely incredible so
guys sit back watch and enjoy
why don't we run away
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
folks a city where humankind and monster
folks live in peace has been taken over
by a cool monster folk General and given
birth to a new era of human oppression
and violence can you when the
adventurer's guilt defeat darlock and
the evil at the Heart of the City
[Music]
you're in my way
[Music]
to relax
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
don't suppose you want to talk this out
[Music]
please stop the files
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I remember how excited I felt the first
time those trailers dropped and how
extremely proud I was to see all of
these developers who are part of black
voices and gaming like we have some more
coming up but red go ahead and introduce
us tell us what else we have going on
thanks Destiny yes we have another set
of some awesome game developers with
black voices and gaming so stay tuned
for the next showcase
can you play something
for their friends and family
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
your distraction machine
will it save our people
or lead us to ruin
[Music]
good morning
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
oh my God I loved it can I just say the
first thing I noticed is not only the
diversity and in skin tones and
representation but also body
representation and that is yes I really
don't see that often and I just I was
just like yes let's bring the cuddly
girl with the big hugs through yes but
let's get right into it Danny D welcome
to Black voices and gaming it is a
pleasure to have you on oh my gosh it's
a huge pleasure to be here thank you so
much it's a matter it's amazing
I know you guys are busy so to have
developers take a little bit of time to
come on and just like chit chat with us
is always like an honor but let's hear a
little bit about you how you got started
in the game realm like girl give us all
the deets
oh Lord okay I mean for me I've been
playing games for a long time
um I always I always gotta credit Mortal
Kombat and I always got a purpose like
but I got it but I got a question like
for the parents out there because I
started that early like I was like me
too
yeah yeah right right maybe not
something to replicate but it definitely
was something that I just got up to and
I I was so into it I got really into
um like I guess just competitive
um fighting games in general but I also
just like I really liked the story like
I I really got into
um you know the whole story of like the
best of the best fighting in a
tournament to save Earth
um so I got really into like the
competitive aspect but also I was very
into the world that they they built with
Mortal Kombat so I don't know that's
following I got an MK system right here
okay
yeah no I I got really into the girls
too like those were my girls like the
like Lena oh yeah I mean Sonia OG right
but that may introduce like Katana and
Laguna I got really into them and I got
into Jade as well my brown skinned
princess like yeah very excited I was so
I was so into it so yeah that just kind
of
um that fed me into playing more and
more I got into both like story based
games but also I got into more
competitive games and then I finally was
just like
you gotta do it you gotta try it um so
that's that's how I ended up here uh
like I'm always so like
what's the word I'm like inspired by
people who play competitive games
because I can't do it like like I was
kid though
I'm not good so therefore I don't even
want to play at least you play like I
can't I think I'm gonna force you to
play some competitive oh my God please
not like OverWatch I don't want to play
it again anyway so but I'm just like
terrible at competitive games I get
really mad I'm just like I'm done but
enough about me this is not about me
this is about Danny D tell us more about
the game hi hello girls because like
just from the trailer I'm really
intrigued like I love the fact that it's
an all-female cast I'm just gonna say
that again I love the fact that it is an
all-female cast because I don't know
many games that do that I don't know
many games that like when they do have a
female protagonist she has to be sexy
and like it's like what about the home
girls out here because we're all out
here all shapes and sizes so red is
going to throw the game up but yeah can
you tell us a little more about what
inspired you to make this game
yeah um
honestly just so being in those sorts of
spaces and being around you know like
like women also Femmes like you know
just kind of non-binary people as well
um basically people who weren't men and
just kind of like acknowledging that
we're definitely there we are definitely
there
um I think there's this kind of a
misperception of the kind of people who
play those types of games
um so it just was more about me wanting
to reflect my own experiences
um we may not be hypervisible because
there's there's some challenges that
come with that sort of hypervisibility a
lot of you know like I'll talk to some
girls especially who are very very
um capable you know they're very high up
on like the competitive ladder so to
speak they're just not public about it
because with that kind of visibility
comes some really unfortunately uh
unpleasant experiences sometimes so yeah
it was more just like look there's
there's this misperception of like who's
playing these games we're definitely
there
um and it just it was like a I had this
drive to at least try to put something
out there that was reflective of my own
experience
I think that's important I like that you
kind of touched on the fact that like
there are tons of people playing these
games but because the community can be
so toxic we're afraid to say that like
yeah I'm a girl and I love playing
competitive games because like as soon
as you say that somebody's gonna have
something next some dude is going to
have something negative to say it's
usually men who have something negative
yeah you can't you're my first
experience online yeah
um it's not me trying to like uh blanket
make a blanket statement but that is
like usually the the thing that happens
so I think it's wonderful that you have
taken your experiences and turned this
into a game what I also think is
incredible is that like for someone like
me who doesn't play competitive games I
can kind of get the story by playing
games that I do like like I love visual
novels I love like falling in love and
making relationships and stuff like that
because my life is terrible so I live
okay but um no this is this is
incredible like this the art style and
everything so can you tell me a little
bit about how you decided to go with
this particular art style and why you
picked the characters that you picked
because I see a lot of representation in
the game
um
man yeah it's it's one of those things
where so I I love visual novels you know
as well like I I've played ultimate
games I played like horror visual novels
um and I think visual novels for a long
time were pretty closely associated with
um mainly Japanese visual novels
um but around like 2015 we had this kind
of influx of West uh Western Indie
developers kind of getting into the mix
and supplying
um kind of non-anime forward art styles
and I was I was pretty inspired by that
and then of course you know I feel like
the big one that everyone is aware of um
that has an art style that's a bit
different from like your typical
um Japanese Ultimate Game or you know
just Japanese visual novel is dream
daddy
okay and so I feel like that's that's
kind of a touch a touchstone in the
space for you know people who if they
think of a visual novel they might think
of either like you know Japanese visual
novel visual novels or they might think
of something like Daddy
um and we were just kind of like you
know we want to capture the sort of like
vibrancy of like a Shonen anime with
like you know like just kind of warm
colors bright colors and expressiveness
that comes through like
um the lead character's mom gets like a
little vein throb
um whenever she's like big time mad at
you you're talking to which I feel like
is very influenced by my own love of
anime
um but we did want to sort of you know
go for a more western style just to
start adding
um a game to that kind of like visual
lexicon I think maybe
um yeah yeah so that wasn't that wasn't
a difficult um in terms of heading in
that direction uh are correctly so
um but as far as the characters go again
just kind of are
they're very reflective of people that I
know you know like I know the cosplayer
I know the streamer
um I know like the person who's like
low-key really really good but just like
not visible about it in any capacity I
know the person who's like kind of toxic
in their own right
um like aggressive you know you look at
her and you're like oh she she wants to
fight
um
is is really about trying to like
capture you know familiarity and the
kind of people that I've been around
um for like the past decade of playing
these kinds of games
um and then also trying to solidify them
in like the visual design so you can
kind of look at them and and kind of
know almost like or get a sense of their
personality
um by just kind of glancing at them and
taking a look at the same time hoping
for them to come through is just like
very well-rounded characters as well so
you know they might start with like ooh
the like really aggressive rocker chick
um I kind of know what her deal is but
as I'm hoping that as you play that you
get like you know a better sense of her
being even more than that you know
there's more going on
um under the surface so fingers crossed
that that comes yeah I I didn't mean to
cut you off I was gonna I was just gonna
say like I love that you you're putting
growth in your characters and making
sure that their personalities are
dynamic because I feel with these types
of games that's really what pulls you in
and once it makes you want to keep
playing right and then you end up
picking your favorite character because
like you can relate to them so I think
that's important that you've put so many
different uh personality types in your
game so even if you're playing as the
main character you can relate to like oh
that's the kind of character I am I love
that character she's my favorite out of
the lineup
another question that I wanted to like
kind of touch on is this is not your
first foray into like gaming like you've
actually worked for AAA Studio correct
I I have not actually but I have relief
just like my own Little Indie stuff um
prior and in the past I I had like a
little brief talents in in games a while
ago that must have been what that was
all right that's really dope though so
like you're not a newcomer to this so
it's great that like you started from
Mortal Kombat to playing competitive
games to actually creating your own game
like this kind of seems like a love
story to like your life and what you
grew up with and what you really like
about the gaming scene and I think
that's very very special and thank you
for sharing that with us
um before we round up anything I'm gonna
throw it to red and let her ask you some
questions about the gameplay
yeah
definitely so
I got come from an Esports background
too and uh one of my loves which I think
is like the heart of Esports period is
the fighting game community so when you
said Mortal Kombat I was like yeah have
and just like you mentioned women a lot
of women are not visible or don't want
to show up because they think they're
not good enough because they see a whole
bunch of guys or even online like my my
first experience online was crazy it was
racial and sexist and all kind of stuff
but some people don't have the thick
skin I just troll back and make them
leave the lobbies but you know some
ladies don't have that
right
I do it to this day
um but what
like to of course were you did you pull
from like that atmosphere in that
culture have you ever been to any
tournaments or or even ask some of the
ladies that's actually because you say
you do know people in the space like
anything that they went through and kind
of wanted to put that in the game as
well to give some texture to context or
anything
absolutely I mean first of all yes like
the fgc
oh I'm so glad you said that because
typically there's like there's Esports
and then there's the fgc where like
people try to make a distinction between
like you know because fighting games
versus right versus versus like
yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna reel it in
because that's a whole rant
um versus like team based you know games
and in the game that they're playing in
Hilo girls is one of those like five
person team based games but I feel like
those experiences as playing someone
from like a marginalized gender are very
Universal across like every kind of
Competitive Gaming you're playing
um so yeah I mean I've gone to Evo a
couple times I love it I've gotten the
combo breaker in Chicago which is like
you know it's kind of like my wonderful
one
um I love I like you know I've seen like
Sonic Fox win tournaments like like I've
seen him when he was little like a kid a
little kid and one against adults
right he just he's just like well yeah
they just kind of came on the scene and
were like with it well I won't swear but
um yeah
there we go there we go
um so yeah I I love going to tournaments
um you know I
I did a little little bit of like there
used to be this site called Major League
Gaming online League
you had the MLG years
I did the MLG where like you might win
like 50 bucks or something off you know
like one of those views and stuff
um and I yeah and I've like I also I've
been following you know competitors who
for like something like the fgc you got
sponsored
um you know you join you join teams and
squads and you know sort of represent
together
um and then for like like a team-based
sort of you know Esports Community
um you know I I watch unfortunately like
all girls teams sort of come and then
there's harassment and you know
sometimes they've got to disband because
it's just it's a very challenging
atmosphere to be in um so yeah I mean
I've I've been around people who've
competed professionally like publicly
and then I've been around
um you know women who
are qualified to do it so they're you
know they're very high up on on
competitive ladders you know might be
trying to field a team or get scouted
but are also running into the
difficulties of you know potentially
being recruited onto like an all-male
Squad and what comes with that and like
there are some dudes in the space who
will outright say really you know sort
of regressive stuff like oh I would
never recruit a female onto my team
because she'll just be a distraction you
know like stuff like that is just these
are sentiments that are out there and
people feel very bold and like they will
say that you know and it's that kind of
thing that
um I've seen I've been exposed to it and
I do want it to come through because
these are undeniable experiences that
people are having
um but I'm also trying to be careful and
that I don't want it to be like an after
school special where it's like oh like
these girls are just facing hardship
like they are but like you said they're
trolling back you know like they are
there because they feel very passionate
very strong about what they're trying to
do so ultimately I like I'm not gonna
shy away from the fact that this is the
climate that they're in but I also want
it to be like a fun game you know I want
people to to not be like depressed as
they're playing this game because it's a
game this character right here reminds
me of me
right right right I I mean it's so yeah
we we do have one who
okay she has like the the blue hair and
the Mohawk and she is Infamous
um for you know trolling back like she
has she has a reputation
um you know to the point where she has
actually been banned multiple times like
her account has been banned multiple
times because she's pretty terrible
um but yeah I mean it's one of those
things where it's like I feel like
people who stay in these spaces as well
they either become that person where
they adapt by just sort of like
adjusting to the vitriol that's thrown
their way or they they might just like
seni who's you know greatest hugs of all
time she's very Zen like they're very
you know they do meditation they do yoga
like they just you know they they take
care of their mental health in that way
um so yeah I just I feel like I feel
like the climate that they're in will
come through and how they're performing
you know their day-to-day lives how they
deal with it rather than
um trying to create a game where it's
like don't you feel bad for you know
these these people all the time even
though like it is real you know it's
like it's a real it's a real experience
to have to go through to want something
like that so
well thank you I I love that you thank
you so much this game and this
experience and for any of the girls out
there who want to play just do it you
have a right to be in this space gaming
is for everyone it's not just for boys
it's not just for men it's for everyone
and when I say that I'm talking about
everybody in the lgbtq plus Community
like
the the fact that people are gatekeeping
we need to like just squash that so if
you see that and you're the type who
wants to get up and say something say
something on behalf of people who are
afraid to say things you know what I
mean absolutely
you're incredible like you're basically
doing that with this game I'm serious
you you took this game and you're really
like shining a light on some of the
issues and I think that's very important
while also still making it fun and
entertaining but
before we wrap up if people want to find
out more about you and the game can you
drop your socials
yeah absolutely
um so we really are focused on Twitter
at the moment
um so our Twitter is split underscore
fate
um and that's actually where you know as
a studio we're talking a lot about um
high yellow girls we're recently doing
like character threads and just sort of
um trying to show off the game and what
you can kind of expect you know
promoting our characters and our our
lovely little world that we've built um
and then my personal is also um it is at
epistellar so Epi s-t-e-l-l-a-r
um and on there I would say fair warning
I get real geeky I talk about you know I
talk about Esports but I also talk about
stuff that's really pissing me off and
it you know it might be racism
right after this so don't even worry
because there's all kinds of things I
say but Danny thank you so much for
taking time to be on here yes for being
a part of black voices and gaming
because it's so important that we we
open up these opportunities and being a
black woman who's in the gaming space
and creating games and developing like
that I hate to see it yo I love to see
it I'm so excited so again thank you for
taking out some of your time for being
with us it was an absolute pleasure and
guys stay tuned because we have a lot
more coming up
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ice cream foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like I love the whole hip-hop Vibe like
it really brought it to life like the
game we're about to see in play and the
documentary really brought it to life
and let us actually know more about Sue
the real but we're gonna jump more into
pseudoro because we have the staff here
we have the team and the crew here uh
welcome everyone thank you so much for
for joining us what black voices and
gaming so we have Marco Silva the
beautiful Raquel motor
and we also have
Jose Wilson AKA Z
[Music]
what's up everyone thank you so much for
coming on spending some time with us and
sharing the game I I love the fact that
you you mentioned earlier that like
you've been kind of following black
voices in gaming and now you're here
which is incredible so like yo excited
excited to have you but I'm gonna throw
it over to Red because she has a lot of
questions that she wants to get into I
have a lot of questions I just want to
say thank you thank you so much for like
showcasing afro Brazilian culture
um actually representing us as well as
far as a whole African diaspora across
the world but actually seeing it you
know in Brazil uh so I love that so I
wanna ask y'all if y'all can please
introduce yourselves Marco we could
start with you and uh let us know what
is your connection or what you do with
Sudan bro
hi everyone
my name is Marco Silva and I'm a game
developer CTO and programmer and in one
bit me I contribute with everything is
invisible and if you have some problem
is probably it's my fault
oh no I love
I always always have I'm fixing
everything and I'm very connected with
the theme of one with me the hip-hop
future are very connected to my children
who history at the same time I love
music I love gain Arts expressions in is
a good pleasure working black people and
work in this community because it's
connected to
personal things
of my life and for me it's so important
working if I can win that too
I love that and we have Raquel Moda what
is your connection and what do you do
with super bro
um oh thank you for be here and I'm okay
and I you uh uh sorry I like games says
there was a kid so when I grow up I
studied more games and now with Studio
views we found with me and Marcos and
now I work as a game developer and CEO
from the scenario and sometimes I write
his script script in our games here
awesome and last but not least Z
how are you and
what is your connection with to the
world what do you do over there with the
crew hi everyone my name is Jose I am
art director at the studio Rio I working
with Marcus and our chaos since from the
beginning of this studio mostly uh
uh contribute in the projects with as
artists and wrap up the the art
Direction
uh aim in the
with Direction the the visuals of the
projects are going and the
battery a lot of arts and drones across
the time with this amazing team so yes
so Z right back at you because we just
came off of watching that incredible
documentary how did that come about and
how was the passion to actually like
bring to life what one beat men is going
to be about into something so incredibly
like visualization of it how did that
come about
the hippie heartbeats sprinting
everywhere in music video clips
animations movies and we think and also
in games but we are really looking for a
hate reduce this subject for a new
audience with uh or perspective about
how the good things that we learn and
and live from the hip-hop culture and in
terms of art style we want to show this
uh shining side about shine insight
about the culture about the colorful the
respect you know the friendship and I
try uh
TransPass this to the art style
to make the subject more welcome to a
new audience but I also bring back
who everyone followed this this kind of
topics in a fresh way you know
zargo
I love that because I've never seen a
like we've had hip-hop games in the past
of course I love how y'all all mentioned
that we wanted to show a Different Light
of the hip-hop culture and nothing so
stereotypical or negative especially
when it surrounds us as black people and
the culture that we have uh connected to
hip-hop so Raquel I learned something
interesting about you that aside from
game development you also study plants
and you mentioned how plants actually
like help you with your game development
can you let us know more about that
oh yes
um it's it's my hobby because I love
nature a lot so everything I saw in my
day is a is a aspiration for me and when
I said plants I try to connect with our
um our things here
um it's it's the parts of a meat for a
long time because uh I I don't know why
but size I was kid my parents show a lot
for me how I can take care more uh with
my space the nature and family and when
I recognize I reconnect these things in
my in my life I feel better so when I
saw a plant sometimes I I didn't I I
think he
my my hair and other things I have in my
body so this is uh inspiring inspire me
to create new things in one between and
other uh other oh sorry how how can I
say uh Opera
oh
this project
uh creating new uh projects here so it's
so special because
um I I think he introduced more this
nature and plants in our game on kitchen
is a plan for the future but with that I
think about this now
that's really interesting I thought that
was really unique
um to have something aside from gaming
all the time to inspire you and your
work now Marco you have a a cool
philosophy you mentioned late you
mentioned earlier how if something's
messed up it's all your four of your
fault but you have a really cool
philosophy on how you look upon things
especially development where you say uh
done is better than perfect uh can you
let us know more about that because in
game development or a lot of things
period when you're working on projects
you can sometimes be in a perfectionist
is a is a curse more than actually being
a blessing so let us know more about why
you chose that philosophy
oh I need to say I I think I learned
about this with Z because I'm
programming and I always looking for my
process as uh oh I need to improve that
in that but Improvement thing can be
infinitive no and sometimes you need to
look for eye spot and make it step by
step your progression and I think if
this when when I change this mentality
this helped a lot is because we
understand we don't start our career at
the same place a big company and make
this comparing our journey in these
companies is so Injustice with us you
know and I think it refers the things
work bad when we put and
smaller objectives for those things and
I think this philosophy done is better
than perfect it's it's because we love
to have a connection with people are
playing our game and if you don't finish
the game the people don't play I like
this yes I prefer the people who play
the game
and not work perfectly but have a
connection
that's a great segue because we're going
to jump right into one beat men right
now and y'all gonna help me as well too
and then we're gonna actually ask some
questions so let's jump right into one
beat men and check it out
awesome oh my God this game looks so
good and the music in it is absolutely
incredible I just wanted to say I can
tell that this is a love letter to
hip-hop to Black Culture and I think you
guys have nailed it it's great and the
fact that you were talking about
um make sure it's done and not perfect
it's because you want people to have
that experience and life is not perfect
so like going in and just being able to
experience this that's the most
important thing and I love that you're
pushing that agenda with this game but
before I ask any more questions let's
kind of get into the game start it up
and I'm gonna let red handle this
because like I said she's a pro
[Music]
the pressure the pressure is on
so it's like Beatboxing with it so how
would I start off to make sure I beat
this brother right here on the train
I will give you a short summary so in
this demo version you we introduce two
characters for our posters uh so you
will need to choose your setup to play
and uh set up the
CPU to to be your opponent so you can
pick any one of these shoes
after this you already choose the tracks
we have three tracks working Brothers
now
and they go it's
looking the sequence of your opponent
and copy in the same the same inputs in
the clockwise Direction but in the beat
the music this is the goal got it
[Music]
I think I feel
you got this
oh my God this is dope
so it's like a rap battle but yeah
[Music]
the fact that they're using like sounds
it reminds me of
what that is but it's like
um Billy Holiday used to do it Ella
Fitzgerald was like amazing at using her
voice just to make different sounds and
beats and this is incredible
while we're playing it and why we have
this amazing music track going on in the
background I did have a few questions
what is it like being a black developer
in Brazil like what is the gaming
industry like in Brazil because I only
know what it's like in the US and I'm
super excited to hear because I know
that you guys have one of the biggest
conferences in the world for gaming
there
perfect
[Music]
I think he's he uh be a black game
developer and in Brazil is a good thing
because we are have an opportunity to
put the RQ during our referential in
your games at the same time it's so hard
because here in Brazil we our we have a
problem to
to start our career in game
equipment is so
so I forgot the word and it's expensive
expensive and this maybe hotels in that
difficult difficult way to start our
career
at the same time I think it is so good
to be in in a country we have the most
part of population as a black people
in these connectors with our
future in a
imaginary of black children
that's awesome and I know like you guys
had some help from the black developer
game fund can you talk a little bit more
about how that has helped you reach the
success of the game
okay I anybody can answer I'm sorry I'm
not like okay I'm literally throwing it
Whoever has the answer go for it
okay
I'm gonna pick Raquel okay ready I'll go
oh
it's so important in our trajectory
because
um this fans make our dreams possible
um we're trying to developing
um one bedroom for
2018. uh yes and
it's crazy because all the time we need
to work in two three jobs to make this
working in in our company and it's not
good and uh because uh in a moment we
need to focus on one thing and the black
development
um made this possible we can
um
focus in one activity and we do our best
all the time to give you our players
more fun and giving us a moment show
brief and safe for us it's okay we can
we can do that uh in our in our way so I
I don't know how to explain this and I'm
not I'm a person I'm emotional personal
when talk about this because uh it is
important and in everything you saw in
this demo because uh our team working a
lot all the time uh to try
um
sorry I want to try our best and when we
saw our community here we saw a lot of
people proud of us uh because we we grow
up a lot in this process and it's not
make sure
um in a simple phrase but it's so
important
[Music]
it's wonderful and and I'm really glad
that you talked about like how you were
able to like step away and really focus
on this because of the black developer
fun because that's really important and
that's what it's about it's about
opening up new doors and allowing you to
really focus on what you're passionate
about
you guys I absolutely love the game it's
incredible like I couldn't stop like
dancing while she was playing it yeah
um I was like yeah I was I was walking
with it but yeah I love it I love how
y'all Encompass a lot of pillars of
hip-hop too within it from the style the
beat beat boxing and stuff I love battle
rap so I I stay close to hip-hop period
I'm from New York city so it's a must
anyway
um but I really love the the
representation I love that y'all are
doing what y'all doing
and being brave in it too uh and
Unapologetic uh with our culture as well
so
um destiny you have anything else to add
no just thank you thank you so much for
coming on and if anybody else wants to
find out information about you and the
game can you plug your socials let us
know where we can find out if you have a
Discord if you have a Twitter we want to
support you and we want our viewers to
support you
so thank you for for the space and in
the invite guys uh it is uh really
really a pleasure to to be here and if
anyone want to see more about what we
are doing you can follow us in the our
main site uh sudario.com or Twitter also
uh so the real uh we have a Twitter
account for the game also and as soon as
possible we are sharing uh Beauty
foreign
all right awesome thank you so much for
coming on thank you for taking the time
to share your incredible game you guys
are doing magic and we appreciate it
well
that was pretty incredible
I love I love it I love it I love all of
it and I just love seeing a game that
represents us you know what I'm saying
like our music our style oh my God our
music our style of melanin
culture like everything hands on I love
it so that was one beat men so check for
it soon
and we got to meet some really
incredible Talent today like from it's
been an international black voices and
gaming showcase uh from the UK Brazil uh
we also had lady developers on here as
well which has been amazing so I'm
really glad that they were able to to
pretty much bring forth their their
dreams their talents and showcase for us
so Destiny how has it been for you
yo this show was dope the fact that we
have gone Global basically like we've
gone Global we're bringing in developers
from all over the world bringing
minorities together to see these amazing
developers and their talent I mean like
I couldn't ask for more but we also need
to thank the people who helped us put
this showcase together year after year
so let's go through and let's give a
shout out to our partners for today's
show first up we have raw Fury who has
helped us from the start like
I'm saying they've been team black
voices and gaming from the beginning we
have PlayStation everybody knows about
PlayStation we have Intel Game Dev boost
we also have ID at Xbox we have Razer we
have Kickstarter but we also want to say
a huge thank you to the team at the mix
and media one our broadcasting Partners
twitch gaming IGN Steam and Gamespot
thank you for joining us today thank you
for listening to the developers tell
their story and share their games and
don't forget to check out merch because
like what's a good show without some
swag you know
is
you need it you gotta gotta get the full
dress
and and also a representation make sure
you check out the steam page which is
our mix uh event page where you'll be
able to check out black voices and
gaming developers their games you can
support them by buying and also add them
to your wish list add them to the games
that's about to come out even if they're
not out yet and wish list them and be
sure to keep up with us the whole bvig
family you can follow us on our Twitter
page which is BVI gaming and also check
us out on IG and YouTube which is black
voices and gaming as well and our uh
website black voices and gaming.org
also we're gonna have black voices and
gaming at day of the devs uh to Showcase
some games there so stay tuned for that
event
and yo I just must say like
everything has been incredible I really
thank you so much Destiny I've been your
co-pilot you know you're in the best
player two in the building
this was so fun chatting with everyone
thank you so much for all the Developers
for participating in Black voices and
gaming and one thing that's really dope
about this showcase as a whole it shows
light to marginalize voices black
developers that want to have their game
out there we're in a really huge
industry so for those who don't
understand when it comes to a snuffed
out voice we need showcases like this in
actual a whole community and funding to
make sure that these developers get
support so I hope it has shed some light
inspired everyone and also have some
titles to look forward to and I am bread
infamy your master geek Chris you can
follow me across the web it's red and
for me on everything also check out geek
game tight and hidden code
destiny
red listen it's it's so hard to say
goodbye you know I'm saying like I could
be here all day long but we got thank
you thank you bring it in bring it in
but in closing
So Yesterday okay I'm sorry anyways guys
thank you in closing we just like to say
the black voices in gaming will continue
to focus on providing funding opening up
doors and creating opportunities for
minority game developers we will
continue to strive so that you can be
heard and seen you're doing important
work and setting the foundation for a
more open and diverse Community for
developers Publishers and Gamers alike
thank you for pursuing your dreams and
please know that black voices and gaming
will always be here to support you
if you want to know more about me you
can always catch me over at the burnout
brighter podcast as well as bonus level
over at level one gaming a site that's
my minority owned and celebrates an
uplifts black voices in The Gaming
Community last but not least you can
always hit me up on Twitter at dnbc32
that's the end of our show and we hope
you enjoyed it as much as we enjoyed
being here and sharing off all of this
amazing talent and speaking to these
incredible people guys stay tuned
because we're gonna have more showcases
we're not going to stop and we're going
to keep going and you're welcome to join
us so thank you we love you stay safe
out there and we will see you next time
peace
[Music]
[Music]